MADE IN AB.
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT OUR BODY CAMERA
TRANSPARENCY BILL WHICH WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR
BROWN LAST YEAR -- THE DRAFTING
YEAR OLD MADE IT SEVEN WORDS
THAT WERE CRITICAL TO CLARIFYING --
WHEN THE BODY CAMERA FOOTAGE
COULD BE RELEASED SO WE ARE
CARRYING THIS BILL AND WE WE
COMMITTED?
TO HI KAREN THIS BILL TO ADDRESS
THAT DRAFTING HERE LAST YEAR
WHEN THE BILL PASSED AND WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW SO.
I RESPECT ASTRIDE VOTE ON A. B..
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU CAN NEVER
WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING WOULD BE PROUD
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATIONS COMMONSENSE FIX AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
MANAGER MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FROM
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA -- CO SPONSORED
THE BILL LAST YEAR ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE LOVE THESE BRIEF WITNESSES
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BUT ENSURE MEMBERS TEMPLES OUT
ON BEHALF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THIS
IMPORTANT CLEAN UP THANK YOU.
GREAT.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
MY GOODNESS WE'RE STARTING OUT
WELL -- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
THE BILL NOW YEAH.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SELL SCORE
ANYWAY -- SEEING NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS MISTER KING YOU
MICHAELIS DISRESPECT YES RIGHT --
EXCELLENT WE WILL ACT ON IT --
ONCE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM NOT
MY SECOND YES PLEASE GO AHEAD I
FORGOT YOU HAS TO THE DAILY LIFE
TEEN RIGHT.
TWELVE FIFTEEN FANS THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE IN
BODY CAMERAS -- AS YOU KNOW THE
ADVENT OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE IS STILL IN ITS INFANCY.
AS IT'S BEING USED NOW IT IS
FAIRLY ACCURATE -- FOR EXAMPLE
AMAZON'S RECOGNITION FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE -- WHEN
CROSS REFERENCE WITH -- THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
MUGSHOT MISIDENTIFIED TWENTY
EIGHT SITTING MEMBERS.
OF CONGRESS I INCLUDING ONE OF
OUR FORMER COLLEAGUES --
CONGRESSMAN JIMMY GOMEZ -- SO
WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY REALLY NOT
READY FOR PRIME TIME.
WE REALLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
PASS A BILL TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T USE.
THIS -- SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE AS
YOU RECALL BODY CAMERAS WERE
REALLY.
OF THE TECHNOLOGY WHICH WAS
FIRST BE USED SO THAT.
WE COULD BUILD TRUST WITH
COMMUNITIES REALLY BUILD TRUST
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITIES.
WE DON'T WANT IS FOR KEEPING IS
TO FEEL LIKE THEY'RE UNDER
SURVEILLANCE TWENTY FOUR HOURS
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK WHEN THE
OFFICER'S BODY CAMERA.
ARE BEING WARNED -- IF YOU TALK
TO ACTS ON IT WHICH IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST PRODUCERS OF BODY
CAMERAS THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THEY SHOULD BE -- DEPLOYING
FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE IN
THEIR BODY CAMERAS -- SO AGAIN
WE REALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB.
TWELVE FIFTY GO AHEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
A GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY MY NAME IS MATT
CABLE AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AT THE
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
I'M ASK I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE FIFTEEN THE BODY
CAM ACCOUNTABILITY ACT SO I JUST
WANT FOLKS TO IMAGINE WALKING
DOWN THE STREET AND BEING FORCED
TO CONSTANTLY SHOW YOUR
IDENTIFICATION. TO POLICE
WITHOUT ANY SUSPICION WHATSOEVER
AT THE SAME TIME YOUR LOCATION
IS BEING LOGGED -- WHETHER
YOU'RE AT CHURCH AT A PROTEST OR
JUST STEPPING OUTSIDE ON YOUR
FRONT PORCH.
THAT IS THE WORLD THAT AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN PROTECTS AGAINST.
AB TWELVE FIFTEEN CODIFIES
EXISTING CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIANS BY
PROTECTING OUR BY PREVENTING THE
USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION AND
OTHER BIOMETRICS WITH BODY
CAMERAS.
AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING SAID.
CAN'T ABIDE CAMERAS WERE
PROMISES A TOOL FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY NOT AS A SYSTEM
TO TRACK AND IDENTIFY
CALIFORNIANS.
RESEARCHER AFTER RESEARCHER HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT FACE
RECOGNITION IS AN ACCURATE AND
RACIALLY BIASED.
BODY CAMERA MAKER AXON HAS SAID
HE IS NOT ACCURATE ENOUGH FOR
POLICE OPERATIONS.
AND TO OUR KNOWLEDGE NO
CALIFORNIA POLICE AGENCIES USING
BODY CAMERA ARE USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION OF BODY CAMERAS.
HI THIS BILL IS NOT DEPRIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF ANYTHING IT IS
ACTUALLY USING.
BUT THE NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE
ACTION IS CLEARER THAN EVER
MICROSOFT JUST ANNOUNCED THAT IT
HAS REFUSED TO PROVIDE A
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY WITH A SURVEILLANCE FOR
BODY CAMERAS CITING HUMAN RIGHTS
CONCERNS.
THE DEPLOYMENT OF THIS FLOOD
TECHNOLOGY WILL LEAD TO
ADDITIONAL DANGERS ENCOUNTERS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
PUBLIC.
AND PEOPLE WHO FEAR BEING
TRACKED WILL POTENTIALLY AVOID
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE OR SEEKING
HELP FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S WHY 62% OF LIKELY TWENTY
TWENTY VOTERS IN A MARCH POLL
FROM THIS YEAR AGREED A BODY
CAMERA SHOULD BE USED SOLELY FOR
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY.
NOT FOR SURVEILLANCE OF THE
PUBLIC. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON A. B.
TWELVE FIFTEEN THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES. TO HELLO MY
NAME IS NATE AND SHARES MY
PLEASURE TO SPEAK WITH YOU THIS
MORNING REPRESENT ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB TOP FIFTEEN THE BODY CAM
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
TECHNOLOGY DOES HAVE THE POWER
TO IMPROVE OUR LIVES YOU CAN
MAKE A GOVERNMENT MORE
ACCOUNTABLE AND EFFICIENT THANKS
BOTH THIS NEW INFORMATION.
BUT CAN ALSO CHILLER PRIVATE.
IT CAN ALSO INVADE OUR PRIVACY
AND CHILLER FREE SPEECH.
WITH ME IS ACROSS THE STATE
CALLS FOR BROADER IMPLEMENTATION
OF POLICE BODY CAMERA USAGE.
THEY DID SO WITH HOPES THAT
GREATER TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY WOULD FACILITATE
TRUST BETWEEN RESIDENTS
PARTICULARS IN MARCH LAST
COMMUNITIES.
AND THE OFFICERS WERE TO PROTECT
THEM.
HOWEVER TODAY WE STAND AT A
CROSSROADS AS FACE RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY CAN NOW BE INTERFACED
DIRECTLY WITH BY THE ONE CAMERAS
pINTENDED TO IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
INTO MASS BIOMETRIC SURVEILLANCE
NETWORK.
FACE RECOGNIZING TECHNOLOGY HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH ERROR
RATES FOR WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
MAKING MATTERS WORSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CONDUCTING
FACE THE VALVES OFTEN RELY ON
IMAGES PULLED FROM MUGSHOT
DATABASES WHICH INCLUDE A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR DUE TO RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AS A RESULT FACE AVAILABLE
EXACERBATED STRUGGLE BIASES BORN
UP AND CONTRIBUTING TO UNFAIR
POLICE.
PLEASE PRACTICES IN BLACK AND
LATINO X. NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE STATE REQUIRES TRUST BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITIES THEREFORE TO PROTECT.
THE REALIZATION OF FACE
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY AND
CONNECTION WITH POLICE BODY
CAMERAS.
WOULD FORCE CALIFORNIA TO DECIDE
BETWEEN ACTIVELY AVOIDING
INTERACTION AND COOPERATION WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OR HAVING YOUR IMAGES COLLECTED
ANALYZED AND STORED.
AS FOR POTENTIAL CANDIDATES OF
SUSPICION.
NOT ONLY WITH THIS FOR THE VOTE
COMMUNITY RELATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT IN FACT ESCALATE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF A TRAGIC
OUTCOME TO EACH INTERACTION.
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE HI.
ON AB TOP [inaudible]
FIFTEEN THANK.
I'M GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
BEFORE WE CONTINUE CAN WE HAVE
ROLL CALL PLEASE ENTER.
YOUR SKINNER HERE MOORLACH
PRESENT WELL I CARE BRADFORD.
RIGHT FOR HERE JACKSON HERE
JACKSON HERE MITCHELL MORALE.
WIENER.
SO THAT MEANS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
A AT LEAST HAVE MOTIONS AS WE
CONTINUE.
LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER --
WELL LET'S A SINCE WE DID ROLL
CALL WE JUST HAVE MEMBER WANTED
TO ADD [inaudible]
OKAY.
SAY HERE.
HERE.
OKAY.
WERE PRESENT ANYWAY -- LET'S SEE
IF THERE ARE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YOU CAN COME TO THE
STANDING MIKE.
THE END OF THE TEARS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND IF THERE ARE MORE
THAN ONE ONE IF YOU MAY NEED.
TO LEAVE THE YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
SIR TO AT THE TABLE IN ONE OF
THE MIKE.
AND I'M SURE MEMBERS COURSE ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL WINNER STAND THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
ABOUT.
PARTICULAR USE OF TECHNOLOGY --
I I THINK WE WOULD WE WOULD NOTE
THAT -- THE RESPONSE THESE
CONCERNS -- IT IS AN APPROPRIATE
IN TERMS OF A BLANKET BAN -- THE
THE PROPONENTS NOTE AND I THINK
WE LARGELY AGREE THAT.
IF THIS TECHNOLOGY IS IN USE
IT'S NOT IN WIDE USE AND THE
RESPONSE TO THESE CONCERNS WELL.
THEY MAY BE FAIR CONCERNS. TO
TAKE AWAY THAT AUTHORITY TO TAKE
AWAY A TOOL COMPLETELY WITHOUT
SORT OF ANY.
THE NOTION OF LET'S ADDRESS WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS -- THAT IT WOULD
JUST THINK IT'S A IT'S AN
INAPPROPRIATE RESPONSE I THINK
THERE ARE -- POTENTIALLY VERY
STRONG USES FOR THIS TECHNOLOGY
WHETHER IT'S HELPING REDACTING
BODY CAM FOOTAGE MAKING SURE
THAT -- CERTAIN PEOPLE SHOULDN'T
BE IDENTIFIED WHEN THE FOOTAGE
IS RELEASED -- HELPING TO
IDENTIFY SUSPECTS OR EXONERATE
POTENTIAL SUSPECTS -- IT JUST
JUST AGAIN THIS THIS TAKING AWAY
OF THE TOOL -- WITHOUT SORT OF
ANY YOU KNOW LET'S HAVE A
DISCUSSION LET'S HAVE A LOOK
HAVE A COMMUNITY MEETING WHAT'S
HAVE A SOME STANDARD WHERE WE
LOOK AT WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSES.
WE JUST WE'RE I THINK WE'RE JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT TAKING WITH IT
TOO I THINK THE OTHER NOTION TO
IS THAT -- THE BODY CAMS ARE
SOLELY FOR OFFICER TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY I THINK A
SHORT SIGHTED THEY CLEARLY HAVE.
INVESTIGATIVE USE THEY HAVE USE
THAT NOT ONLY -- PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FROM YOU KNOW MISBEHAVIOR
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
THE EXTENT IT HAPPENS IT ALSO
PROTECTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS FROM.
CRIMINAL OR MISS BEHAVIOR OF THE
PUBLIC AND IT HELPS TELL A STORY
IT'S NOT A PANACEA IT DOESN'T
REVEAL EVERYTHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED AND OFTEN DISPLACE ONE
ANGLE.
AND ONE PERSPECTIVE BUT IT DOES
HELP TELL A STORY AND SO AGAIN
TAKING AWAY THAT TOOL -- WE
THINK HAS CONSEQUENCES THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY OUTWEIGH THE
PERCEIVED CONCERNED SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK YOU KNOW THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DILUTION
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE --
WE'VE BEEN IN AND I THINK SOME
INITIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE CONCERNING OUR A
POSITION WHICH SUPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED -- NOT -- TO
REGURGITATOR REITERATE -- MOST.
OF MY COLLEAGUE RAISED BUT
THERE'S SOME OTHER ASPECTS TO
FACIAL RECOGNITION THAT WE THINK
ARE ARE I THINK IMPORTANT I
THINK WE WOULD ADVOCATE.
FOR SITTING DOWN AT THE TABLE
AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW
BEST TO REGULATE USE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY I'LL GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES -- WHILE IT'S
NOT WIDELY IN USE IN AND I THINK
THERE IS SOME UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THE MAN ONE OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT ARE ACTUALLY
ACTIVELY USING THIS TECHNOLOGY
THAT THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
CASE -- BUT WE SEE VALUE IN THE
EAST THE TECHNOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE --
TO IDENTIFY MISSING PERSONS.
SO IN ANY INSTANCES WHERE.
YOU KNOW FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY COULD BE USED IN
COMBINATION WITH -- A BODY
CAMERA AS IT RELATES.
TO OF A YOUNG KID YOUNG BOY A
YOUNG GIRL -- PERSON WHO IS
MISSING.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
WOULD YOU WOULD.
CONSIDER A BLANKET BAN WHEN THEY
ARE CLEARLY SOME I THINK
IDENTIFIABLE PERSON UP OF
PURPOSES WITH.
LESS CONTROVERSY I THINK THE
OTHER THING TO CONSIDER.
IS THAT WHILE THE TECHNOLOGY
ISN'T PERFECT IN PERFECT IT
HINGES ON TWO THINGS NUMBER
[inaudible]
ONE ARM.
IMAGE QUALITY AND THEN IT ALSO
HINGES ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SOFTWARE WILL AS IMAGE
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES BECAUSE
CAMERAS IMPROVE -- YOU'RE GOING
TO GET BETTER OUTCOMES IN AND
MORE FINELY TUNED MATCHES AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY IF THE SOFTWARE.
CONTINUES TO IMPROVE.
AT AN ACCELERATED PACE AS IT HAS --
THAT IS ALSO GOING TO AGAIN
IMPROVE WHICH WHICH REALLY ALSO
KIND OF UNDERSCORES DO WE REALLY
NEED A BAND NOW OR ARE THERE
SOME OTHER WAYS IN WHICH WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO REGULATE -- THE
USAGE OF THE TECHNOLOGY OR SET
SOME STANDARDS IN PLACE THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY MAYBE NEEDS TO MEET
CERTAIN THRESHOLDS OF ACCURACY.
IN ORDER FOR TO BE CONSIDERED --
USEFUL.
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT RIGHT NOW
YOU CANNOT USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY SOFTWARE.
TO ESTABLISH PROBABLE CAUSE TO
MAKE AN ARREST -- SO.
PRACTICALLY SPEAKING WHAT THE
USE WOULD BE IS.
YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE SOME SORT OF
COLD CASE AND WE NEED TO TRY AND
NARROW DOWN WHO WAS AT THE SCENE --
SO WE CAN HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS -- BUT THE THOSE
THESE ARE SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE I THINK -- SPOKEN TO
THE AUTHOR ABOUT WE AGREE IT
SHOULDN'T BE USED TO TRACK
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
RACE ETHNICALLY ETHNICITY --
RELIGIOUS OR POLITICAL VIEWS --
AND MAYBE THERE SHOULD BE SOME
SORT OF STANDARD -- THAT SHOULD
BE UTILIZED IN ALL THE PERHAPS A
REASONABLE SUSPICION SUSPICION.
THAT EXIST THAT ONLY A SERIES OF
VIOLENT CRIME HAS BEEN COMMITTED
SO WE'RE WE'RE OPEN TO TALKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ABOUT IT WE
THINK THERE'S A WAY -- TO REDUCE
FEARS THAT OF A POLICE STATE
THAT IS GOING TO BE IN
CONTINUOUS REAL TIME.
SURVEILLANCE -- WITH FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY SO THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE.
M. WE WILL CONTINUE WITH OUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND NINE
WILL.
GO AHEAD WITNESSES NOT.
MY MENTOR MEMBERS RANGE FROM
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION LINE OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE SPEAKERS HERE AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU.
MORE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON ON
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
WHOLE SHARE FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT LOS ANGELES OLYMPIC
GAMES WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
I'M SURE RAINY PERIOD WE HAVE A
PARKING OPPOSE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SORRY MANAGER MEMBERS
ARRANGEMENT AGAIN -- THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF CHAD
BIANCO'S ASKED ME -- TO INFORM
YOU OF HIS OPPOSITION AS WELL
THANKS.
PART ANY OTHERS. NINETEEN NINETY
WE HAVE SAT.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I
APOLOGIZE I WAS A LITTLE LATE ON
MY NAME IS SUMMER HARADA WITH
THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS.
I'M ACTUALLY HERE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL -- AND HELP RAISE AWARENESS
FOR THE CAUSE -- OFFER THIS BODY
IN TERMS OF THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION ABUSE THAT OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS ADVOCACY GROUP HAS BEEN
SEEING -- IN CHINA IN TERMS OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION BEING USED --
TO OVEN PURVEY OF HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUSES AGAINST AN ETHNIC
MINORITY -- AND ONGOING RACIAL
AND RELIGIOUS PROFILING WE'RE
SEEING ON WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SHE WITHOUT ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS WE HAVE
A MOTION.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS YES
SAYS SENATOR JACKSON.
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE SAID IN
HERE ALL OF THE OPPOSITION BUT I
IT -- IT'S OF MY ANDERSON IS THE
REASON AT LEAST YOU'RE SENSIBLE
REASON THAT YOU.
OUR TO BRING IN THIS BILL IS
BECAUSE THIS.
THIS TECHNOLOGY AT THIS PINT
TIME IS INACCURATE.
AND IN ITS.
NASCENT.
US STATE.
I AND THEREFORE RATHER THAN.
GO THROUGH THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LEGISLATION --
OR RATHER WITH FACIAL
RECOGNITION.
BEING INACCURATE AND CAUSING ALL
SORTS OF PROBLEMS.
THE GOAL IS TO JUST OUTRIGHT.
BANDIT.
ON THE OTHER HAND [inaudible]
HAS WAS.
ARTICULATED BY THE OPPOSITION --
OR THE OF THE LA DA -- REPRESENT
PROTECTIVELY THAT.
THERE MAY BE SOME GOOD PURPOSES
FOR AND TO JUST OUTRIGHT DISMISS
IT MAY BE SORT OF IT AND
INAPPROPRIATE.
OF SORT OF A IN A HEAVY HANDED
APPROACH TO THIS AT THIS POINT
TIME -- CLEARLY A LOT OF
POSSIBLE USES ARE OF CONCERN.
AND IN A WE ARE WORRIED ENOUGH
AND SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR USING THIS KIND
OF INFORMATION AND WHERE WE
DON'T SEEM TO OF INDICATED THE
SAME CONCERN THAT WE ARE WHEN IT
COMES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT -- ARE
THERE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE USE OF
THESE BIOMETRIC SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEMS AND MAYBE IT'S THE
OPPOSITION THAT I SHOULD BE
ASKING WHEN THIS KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY.
SERVICE LONG FIRST FORCED ME YOU
MENTIONED -- IDENTIFYING
SUSPECTS OR MISSING PERSONS --
ARE THERE OTHER INSTANCES WHERE
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
YOU BELIEVE IF IT BECOMES BETTER
PERFECTED.
MIGHT SERVE THE PUBLIC INTEREST
WE CAN HEAR FROM -- ONE
OPPOSITION AND THEN I WILL ALLOW
THE I'D APPRECIATE.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DILUTION
LOS ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE -- CERTAINL MISSING
PERSONS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT -- WE'VE CONSIDERED AND
TALKED ABOUT EXTENSIVELY.
THE OTHER WOULD BE INSTANCES
WHERE -- AN OFFICER HAS AN
ENCOUNTER -- WE WE WE SOUGHT IN
A LATE LAST YEAR AN OFFICER AN
ENCOUNTER -- WITH SOMEONE AT THE
OF OSTENSIBLY PULLED OVER FOR
TRAFFIC VIOLATION THAT RESULTED --
IN THE LOSS OF THAT OFFICER'S
LIFE -- YOU COULD CLEARLY
DOWNLOADING TAKE THE BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE BACK. TO THE STATION IN
AN INSTANCE LIKE THAT.
BOMB BUT WHAT SHE WOULD BE
CONSIDERING AT THAT POINT TIME
IS -- OKAY WILL LET'S USE OUR
HUMANIZED TO TRY AND DETERMINE --
IF THERE IS ANYONE WHO LOOKS
LIKE OUR LET'S PUT IT OUT ON
TELEVISION -- LET'S DISTRIBUTED
TO SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHO
THIS PERSON IS -- AND WHILE THAT
YOU KNOW HAS BEEN VIABLE IN THE
PAST IN AND MAY CONTINUE TO BE
VIABLE -- I THINK WE'VE HAD IN A
LOT OF DEBATE IN THIS SPACE
ABOUT THE THE ACCURACY OF
EYEWITNESS -- FOOTAGE AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE SO WE WE REALLY
SEE IT AS JUST KIND OF ANOTHER
TOOL -- TO HELP US IN THAT
ENDEAVOR AND WITH THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION IF I MAY THAT BUT
THAT'S WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
FACIAL NECESSARILY YOU HAVE A
PHOTOGRAPH OF SOMEONE YOU HAVE A
PHOTOGRAPH OF AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT'S AT ISSUE HERE AND IS IT.
IT IS IN MY WAY CORRECT THAT.
THAT THAT CONTINUES BECAUSE
YOU'RE YOU'RE MAKING A RECORD OF
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BUT TO USE
THE BIOMETRIC.
IS THE ISSUE -- AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT THAT IS PERSUASIVE AS TO
WHY WE SHOULD BE CONSIDERING
EXCEPTIONS TO THIS I'M LOOKING --
FOR IF I MAY.
THERE MAY BE A VERY GOOD REASON
[inaudible]
SUGAR MEANT.
GOOD SOLID OF POLICE OF PURPOSE
IN USING BIOMETRIC SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEMS WHAT I'VE HEARD IS RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE NOT THERE BECAUSE
THEY'RE INACCURATE.
AND TROUBLESOME AS FAR AS WHAT
THE LIMITATIONS WOULD BE.
SO I'M TRYING TO SEE ARE THERE
ARE INSTANCES GOING FORWARD
WHERE.
THIS REALLY MAY BE A VALUABLE
TOOL AND THAT WE MIGHT NOT WANT
TO CHOOSE UNIVERSALLY BAN IT.
OR INSTEAD OF LIMITED UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS IT CAN BE SHOWN TO BE
ACCURATE AND PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
A LEGITIMATE ASSISTANCE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S MY QUANDARY
AT THE MOMENT RIGHT YEAH I I
THINK WHAT WE ARE NOT HERE
PLEASE THANK YOU ARE YOU MADAM
CHAIR -- I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THE NOTE THAT THIS BILL COVERS
BODY CAMERAS ONLY IT IS NOT A
BLANKET BAN.
ON FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE --
IN DO YOU MAY BRIEFLY ANSWER AND
THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM THAT
WHETHER THE SUPPORTERS ONE
RESPOND.
ABSOLUTE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AMENDMENT XIV TEENY -- AS WE THE
AS WE KIND OF TOUCHED ON THE THE
BIOMETRIC SOFTWARE -- AS IT'S
CURRENTLY USE IT'S NOT USED IN
REAL TIME.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT IT WOULD
BE USING WOULD BE USED FOR THE
AFTER THE FACT.
AND BUT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
MORE SPECIFICALLY -- THE THE THE
MISSING PERSONS ISSUE IS IS ONE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT
THE LA POLICE.
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE IS RAISED AT
THIS PRESENT TIME WHERE IT WOULD
PROVIDE INSTANT VALUE -- WE
BELIEVE IN TRYING -- TO IDENTIFY
AND OBVIOUSLY REUNITE PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER KING WOULD YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO ANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS YEAH IT IS VERY I
THINK JUST VERY BRIEFLY AND AND
BROADLY.
ON IF YOU COULD IMAGINE ANY CITY
THAT DECIDED TO DEPLOY HUNDREDS
OR EVEN THOUSANDS OF CAMERAS ON
THEIR STREET -- THEY WOULD HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A FAIRLY ROBUST
PUBLIC PROCESS AND EVALUATION IF
THEY IF THEY WANT TO DO A SANTA
BARBARA BERKELEY OR LA.
OR IN IRVINE THEY WOULD HAVE TO
GO THROUGH A FAILY ROBUST
PUBLIC PROCESS.
AND REALLY DELIBERATE WHETHER OR
NOT THE COMMUNITY FELT IT
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE.
CONSTANT SURVEILLANCE ON THEIR
STREETS YES IT WOULD HELP WITH
INVESTIGATIONS YES IT WOULD HELP
OF MISSING PERSONS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW A SINGLE CITY.
IN THE STATE THAT'S REALLY MADE
THIS CHOICE.
BUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS IF YOU
ACTIVATE.
THE FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE
IN OFFICER.
BODY CAMBER'S.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT TO DO.
YOU ARE PUTTING HUNDREDS TO
THOUSANDS [inudible]
OF CAMERAS.
WITH FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE
THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
ON OUR STREETS INSTANTLY.
WITHOUT ANY PUBLIC DELIBERATION.
WITHOUT ANY PUBLIC PROCESS
WITHOUT ANY UNDERSTANDING OR
AGREEMENT AS TO WHAT THEY CAN
AND CANNOT BE USED.
FOR THAT THAT IS REALLY SORT OF
WHAT'S AT STAKE SO -- AGAIN
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE CONCERNS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT -- THEY'VE
ONLY RECENTLY -- ENGAGED IN THIS
LEGISLATION SO WE'RE HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE WORK WITH THEM AND
SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY AMENDMENTS
THAT.
WE COULD ACCEPT IT HAPPY TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THEM THAT THIS
POINT.
THAT IS REALLY WHAT'S AT STAKE
IT IS IS ABOUT A COMPLETE LACK
OF PUBLIC PROCESS OF DEPLOYING
THIS.
SOFTWARE.
ON OUR STREETS WITHOUT US EVEN
KNOWING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
MAKAYLA MAY I THINK WE THE
AUTHORS SUFFICIENT AND WONDERFUL
SO FAR.
SO ON ASSEMBLYMEMBER KING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WE HAVE A
MOTION ALL USE AS MY CLOTHES
DISRESPECT FASTRACK BUT RIGHT --
WE WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
SKINNER HI SKINNER I'M MORE LEFT.
NO WELL I'VE NEVER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL
I'M AROUND NO REAL NOW WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHICH WE CAN ALSO SO THAT BILL.
TIME PASSES -- WE CAN TAKE A
MOTION ON YOUR FIRST ITEM.
AND THAT IS -- AB FIFTY FOUR
IT'S DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION --
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL.
HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WELL NO.
MERRILL NOW WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THE BILL PASSES SIX TWO ONE AND
WE WILL NOW AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KING WILL NOW GO
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY TO
NINETY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ
.
YOU MAY PROCEED
[inaudible] ONE
GO AHEAD HERE YOU HAVE TO PUSH
THE BUTTON AND THEN YOUR MICHAEL
BEYOND GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWO
NINETY FOUR INTEREST AND CAN
EXPOSE THE VICTIM TO A
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE AND CAUSE
TRAUMA.
ACCORDING TO STATE AUDIT ON
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES SOME ARE
FOUND TO NOT HAVE ADEQUATELY
NOTIFIED OFFICERS AND STUFF OF
THE RIGHTS OR THE AFTER CARE
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO THEM AFTER
AN ATTACK.
AND BECAUSE OF UNTIMELY
INVESTIGATIONS AND INCONSISTENT
DOCUMENTATION PROCEDURES.
MANY OF THESE ATTACKS ALSO WENT
UNPUNISHED.
AB TWO NINETY FOUR REQUIRES
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE REGULAR TRAINING TO
STAFF IN RESPONDING TO GAS
ATTACKS INCLUDING A NOTICE OF
THE RIGHTS. TO AFTER CARE
SERVICES AND IMPROVES
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OFFICES.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN SERVE CARTER
COMMUNITIES AND EVERY DAY.
WE ALSO MUST DO WHAT WE CAN HELP
THEM IN GOOD FAITH.
AND GET HEALTH HERE WITH ME THAT
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS
LIEUTENANT BRANDED APP.
FROM THE LAWSON'S COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND JOHN
LEVEL FROM THE LA COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION TESTIFIED.
AHEAD MORNING MADAM CHAIR --
MEMERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE LA COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL PEACE OFFICERS WERE
ONE OF THE UNION TO REPRESENT
EMPLOYEES THERE AND A NUMBER OF
OUR EMPLOYEES.
ARE IN THE JAILS -- THERE THIS
LAST YEAR THERE WERE OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND INCIDENTS OF
GASSING IN LA COUNTY JAIL WE
JUST GIVE ME A SENSE OF WHAT
GASSING IS JUST SO YOU KNOW NOW.
YOU REALLY DO -- BECAUSE HE DID
IT HIGHLIGHTS.
CREDIT T<c.cyan> THINK THERE HAS</c>
BEEN ACTUALLY HERE'S WHAT
HAPPENS.
THE IN MAKE FROZE FECES AND
URINE AT THE AT THE VICTIM
OFFICER BUT THE WAY THEY THINK
HE COULD DESCRIBE CATIONS.
YES THAT THEY MIX THAT WITH
TOOTHPASTE SO THAT IT WILL SPEAK
TO THE OFFICER SKIN THAT'S THE
OBJECTIVE.
THIS IS A CRIME WITH REAL INTENT
THIS IS SERIOUS.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
LIEUTENANT BRANDED UP ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF --
ALEX WE AND WEBER -- OR
DEPARTMENT MEMBERS IN IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUFFER FROM THESE
ATTACKS A FAR GREATER LOT
NUMBERS AND THEN THE REST OF THE
STATE.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE BRAG
ABOUT POSSIBLY A SEEN A
RECRUITMENT FOLDER OR PERMIT
VIDEO -- BUT YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY WE PRIDE OURSELVES
ON HOW WE TREAT OUR EMPLOYEES
BUT AS THE AUDIT -- DISPLAYED
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO NINETY FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
YES NEXT WITNESS THE MORNING
CHEN MEMBERS NAMELY PETRONE WITH
MAKE YOU KEPT IN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS.
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION BENEFIT
TRUST ON'T IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING LIEUTENANT FELISA
WILLIAMS ON BEHALF OF SHARE
MCMAHON SUMMER DINO COUNTY.
IN SUPPORT.
MORNING RANGER WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT AND ALSO FOR RIVERSIDE
CHURCH OF YOUNG CAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I'M ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT AM I WANTED TO INDICATE
THAT I APPRECIATE THE BILL AT
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM I
WOULD ALSO NOTE.
THAT.
AND AND OUR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY STAFF WHETHER IN COUNTY
JAILS OR STATE PRISONS DO
DESERVE TO HAVE TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THERE'S ALSO
BEEN PUBLICITY ABOUT INCIDENTS
UNFORTUNATELY WHERE.
COUNTY CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
HAVE IN EFFECT ENCOURAGED
INMATES -- TO WHILE WHILE THE
TERM GASSING IN OUR STATUTE
REFERS ONLY TO THAT WHICH OCCURS
TO THE CARD.
THE AS A AS A JUST POPULAR
REFERENCE IT COULD HPPEN TO
ANYONE AND THERE HAS BEEN
UNFORTUNATELY PUBLICITY --
ACTUALLY DOCUMENTED INCIDENTS
WHERE SOME COUNTY CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS HAVE IN EFFECT
ENCOURAGED SOME INMATES TO GAS
OTHER INMATES.
SO I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ YOU'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE WHO WOULD PIECE
POSSIBLY SUBJECT TO THIS IS
PROTECTED.
AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
AUTHORS AGREED TO TAKE PROVIDE
THAT IN IN MAY TWO SIX BOWS. TO
AT THIS THE SAME WAY AS A GUARD
COULD BE I HAS THE RIGHT TO BE
TESTED FOR THE SAME THING CITY
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER WOULD.
REQUIRE SAID THE INMATE RECEIVE
NOTICE OF THE RIGHT TO BE TESTED.
AND REQUIRES THAT A ON OUR STATE
PRISON OR COUNTY JAIL DOCUMENT
ALL INCIDENTS SAME AS YOUR AS IS
EXISTS THERE NOW IN THE BILL.
FOR THE CORRECTION OFFICERS WERE
AN INMATE INTENTIONALLY PLACES
ARE THROWS.
AT SUCH MATERIAL ON ANOTHER
INMATE SO APPRECIATE THAT YOU
ACCEPTED THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S AY.
OTHER COMMENTS OR A SENATOR OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
THIS IS A AN APPALLING PRACTICE --
AND I WONDER.
WELL WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT.
AGAINST THE RAMIFICATIONS OF IT
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO TRY.
TO PREVENT THIS AND TO I MEAN.
I DON'T THINK MOST PEOPLE AS
HUMAN BEINGS ARE INCLINED TO
COMMIT THIS KIND OF OR ENGAGE IN
THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY HASN'T
BEEN ANYTHING DONE ANY RESEARCH
DONE ANY.
TRAINING DONE TO TRY TO
DISCOURAGE.
THIS REALLY.
HIS ANIMAL BEHAVIOR -- THIS IS
JUST OF MAYBE I'M NAIVE BUT THE
I FIND THE SHOCKING BEHAVIOR
FIFTEEN THOUSAND EXAMPLES OF
THIS IN PRISON WHAT WHAT IN THE
WORLD IS GOING ON THAT.
THE PEOPLE.
FIND IT APPROPRIATE OR NECESSARY
OR EVEN DESIRABLE TO BEHAVE IN
THIS FASHION.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY DOES THE
AUTHOR WANT TO RESPOND.
I THINK A LOT OF IT -- CAME TO
THE AUDIT.
THAT WAS DONE ABOUT TWO YEARS
AGO TO REALLY FOCUS ON THE ISSUE
BECAUSE WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT IT
RIGHT BUT I THINK THE OTHER
PHONE LOT OF THE INCONSISTENCIES
RIGHT.
SOME DEPARTMENTS NOT REALLY
FULLY -- ADVISING STAFF OR
INMATES ABOUT WHAT GOES ON IN
WHITES GOING ON SO THIS IS
TRYING TO GET EVERYBODY TOGETHER
TO COME UP WITH STANDARD.
TO AT LEAST START TO NOT ONLY
WORK WITH OFFICERS IN THE
DEPARTMENTS BUT ALSO WITH THE
INMATES.
ARE WHY THIS IS HAPPENING AND TO
DISCOURAGE THAT PRACTICE AND NOT
ENOUGH ONE OF MY OF FOLKS HERE
IN SUPPORTER LIKE TO ADD TO THAT
AS WELL I'M NOT SURE IF THEY YOU
KNOW MUCH ABOUT.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING BUT HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL BE -- BEFORE FROM WE
CAN DO TO START.
MINIMIZING THOSE THE TYPES OF
INCIDENTS IS NOT ONLY AT THE
COUNTY FACILITIES BUT AT THE
STATE FACILITIES AS WELL AND I
THINK.
MORE READY LIKE ABOUT IT IS SOME
OF THE INMATES THAT OR IN THE
CASE COUNTY FACILITIES OR ONES
OR WERE IN STATE PRISONS AND I
THINK THAT CULTURE IS KIND OF
COME DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVELS IN
THE COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
AS YOU SEE THROUGHOUT ALL THE
COUNTY FACILITIES BECAUSE A LOT
OF THOSE IN MY THREE OR MORE
KEPT AT THE STATE FACILITIES AND
I THINK FROM THAT CULTURE NOW IS
WENT INTO THE LOCAL LEVEL AT THE
CUSTARD FOR SALUTE PLEASE
[inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU ARE YOU THINK IN
RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUE -- WHEN
PEOPLE ARE TREATED LIKE ANIMALS
WHEN PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN ANIMAL
LIKE CONDITIONS -- WHEN WE JUST
CAME FROM THE -- DISPLAY OUTSIDE
WHERE YOU LOOK AT WHY PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOCKED THAT MAY NOT HAVE
HOPE.
IN TERMS OF OUR EXTENDED
SENTENCES.
ALL THAT WE HAVE PILED ON TO
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED --
WHILE I WAS HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL I THINK IT'S AT A POOR
PRACTICE -- TO GO TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HOW DO WE GET
THERE WHEN I LOOK AT THE
CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH WE HAVE
SANCTION THE PEOPLE LIVE.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING.
TRAGIC BUT NOT SURPRISING MENTAL
I THINK OUR WORK TO TREAT PEOPLE
LIKE HUMAN BEINGS IN ADDITION TO
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS WILL BE
HELPFUL.
SENATOR JACKSON YOU KNOW I I
THINK THAT WAS WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO GET AT HIS SET.
I DON'T KNOW TWENTY MOTHERS OR
FATHERS TO TEACH THEIR CHILDREN
THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR SO HOW
DOES HE GET TO THE POINT WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BEHAVE THAT
WAY AND I WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST
THAT THAT.
BE SOMETHING WE LOOK AT AS WELL
BECAUSE I DON'T.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS CALLING ON
PEOPLE TO BE THEIR BEST AND TO
BE IN A SITUATION WHERE YOU'LL
HAVE FIFTEEN THOUSAND INCIDENTS
OF THAT IN THE LA COUNTY JAIL
TELLS ME.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE
WAY WERE CONDUCTING -- ARE --
INCARCERATIONS SYSTEM AND SO I
HOPE THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE LOOKED AT AS WELL INTO.
WITH THAT I TAKE COMMAND CHAIR
FOR INDULGING ME I I JUST FIND
THIS ABSOLUTELY APPALLING
[inaudible]
I'M.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
OUR SPECTRUM TROUBLE THANK YOU
EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
IT'S DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL.
SKINNER HI SKINNER I'M MORE
LACKEY.
MORE LIKEAYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU.
MORRELL AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM
FIVE AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW -- LET'S
SEE IF WE CAN GET A MOTION ON
CONSENT TO WE CAN DEAL WITH THAT
WHILE THE ALRIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION ON CONSENT WE HAVE ROLL
CALL.
SKINNER HI SKINNER I'M MORE
LACKEY.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON ARE A LITTLE.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND AYE FLORA
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THURMOND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW YOU MAY
BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS SAID.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AB MADAM
CHAIR TODAY A PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR WHICH
WOULD ADD THE COUNTIES OF MONO
SAN MATTEO AND DEL NORTE. TO
SECTION -- EIGHT THREE POINT ONE
OF THE PENAL CODE.
THIS CODE ALLOWS PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS WHO WORK AS
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS THE
ABILITY TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT POWERS WHILE IN
UNIFORM AND ON DUTY THAT
EXPLOSIVELY OR INITIALLY RELATE
TO SPECIFIED BECAUSE CLAUDIO
ASSIGNMENTS.
SOME OF THESE DUTIES INCLUDE
CONDUCTING ROUTINE DAILY
TRANSPORTS SUCH AS TRANSPORTING
INMATES TO AND FROM COURTS AND
POSSIBLY BEING AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST PATROL WHEN NEEDED TO
TRANSPORT.
A THE ARRESTEES TO JAIL.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR
WOULD HELP PROVIDE A MORE
VERSATILE AND LARGER STAFF TO
THESE COUNTIES.
BY ALLOWING THEIR SHERIFF
DEPUTIES TO BE ASSIGNED TO
ENFORCEMENT ROLES AND NOT
CORRECTIONAL RELATED TASKS.
AT THE MOMENT THIRTY TWO
COUNTIES IN THE STATE ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS SECTION CODE.
HERE TODAY WITH ME IS AUDREY --
THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF SAN MATTEO COUNTY --
MEMBERS THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
MEASURE THAT'S PASSED THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY UNANIMOUSLY AND
WHEN APPROPRIATE MANAGER I'D BE
WILLING TO CLOSING ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
ARE THE RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN MATEO COUNTY AND THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE TWENTY FOUR THE BILL WOULD --
PROVIDE ADDED PUBLIC SAFETY
TOOLS TO THE COUNTY OF SAN
MATTEO MONO AND DEL NORTE.
BY ALLOWING PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS WHO WORK AS
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS THE
ABILITY TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT POWERS WHILE IN
UNIFORM AND ON DUTY.
THIS IMPORTANT POLICY WOULD BE A
FORCE MULTIPLIER FOR OUR AGENCY
AND WOULD ASSIST THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE WITH AUTHOR AUTHORIZING
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS TO PERFORM
CORRECTIONS RELATED TASKS.
INCLUDING PROVIDING SECURITY FOR
INMATES AT THE HOSPITAL COMPLETE
DALY TRANSPORT OF INMATES TO AND
FROM COURT AND TRANSPORTING
INMATES BETWEEN CUSTODIAL
OFFICES FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR JEFFREY
LEE **** ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL PEACE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS.
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH CHARM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WRITING NINE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
WE HAVE A MOTION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE.
RIGHT THE MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASSED TO RULES -- ALRIGHT
WHAT'S THE ROLL CALL.
SKINNER BY SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM SIX
AB.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
MANAGER
.
GO AHEAD AND REMEMBER YOU MAY
GET.
Q. MESSENGER AND SANDERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THE
BILL THAT WOULD IMPROVE THE
AVAILABILITY EFFICIENCY AND
QUALITY OF MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAMINATIONS. FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS.
FIRST LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING
THAT MY STAFF HAS WORKED OUT AN
AMENDMENT WITH THE COALITION
AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THAT WILL REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION.
CURRENTLY THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES CALLOW YES TO
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT THAT MAY BE
REIMBURSED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
OFFSET THE COST OF A NON
INVESTIGATIVE.
EXAM EVERY FIVE YEARS.
THE AGREED UPON AMENDMENT WOULD
PROHIBIT CALLOW YES FROM
INCREASING THE CAP BY MORE THAN
50% OF THE MOST RECENTLY
DETERMINED REIMBURSEMENT AMOUNT.
SO WITH THE CAP CURRENTLY SET AT
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS CAL -- YES
COULD INCREASE IT TO FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS AND THEN
IN FIVE YEARS TO SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS AND SO ON
AFTER AND DURING A SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
TIMELY ACCESS TO TRAUMA INFORMED
IN EVIDENCE BASED CARE CAN
PREVENT ADVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND ALLOW FOR THE PROPER
COLLECTION OF EVIDENCE.
AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS ACCESS BY
ENSURING THAT EXAM TEAMS ARE
PAID FULLY FOR CONDUCTING EXAMS
AND BY CLARIFYING THAT NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS MAY PERFORM EXAMS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO OF THE
EXISTING LAW TO REFLECT CURRENT
BEST PRACTICES ENHANCE
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION AND
TRAINING FOR EXAMINERS PROTECT
THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF FORENSIC
RECORDS.
AND GENERALLY IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF CARE FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS.
AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
MADE UP OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAM TEAMS SEXUAL
ASSAULT INVESTIGATORS CRIME LAB
DIRECTORS HOSPITALS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE KIM WALKER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SEXUAL ASSAULT FORENSIC
EXAMINER'S ASSOCIATION.
AND MELINDA WHEELER ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS IGNORE SPECIALISTS
INC I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOUR TIME
TODAY.
MY NAME IS KIM WALKER AND I'M A
BOARD MEMBER AND THE
CALIFORNIA'S SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINER'S ASSOCIATION
A CALIPHATE.
REPRESENTS THE FORTY NINE EXAM
TEAMS IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
I AM ALSO THE PROGRAM MANAGER
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY SEXUAL
SUFFERANCE EXAM OR SAFE PROGRAM.
WHERE WE SERVE PATIENTS FROM
SANTA CLARA SAN BENITO SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY?
MOST IMPORTANTLY I'M A CURRENTLY
PRACTICING SEXUAL SOUGHT NURSE
EXAMINER.
PURPOSE OF AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
IS TO AMEND AND CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE OF THE PENAL CODE WHICH
OUTLINES THE PARAMETERS FOR THE
PROVISION OF MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAMS. TO SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
IMPORTANTLY IT CORRECTS THE
LANGUAGE SURROUNDING THE PAYMENT
FOR MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY SAM'S
UNDER THE VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN
ACT.
THAT IS INCREASINGLY BEING
MISINTERPRETED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS APPLICABLE TO ALL
EXAMS.
IF LEFT UNCORRECTED EXAM TEAMS
ARE AT RISK OF SHUTTING DOWN IS
THIS WILL RESTRICT ONE OF THE
ONLY FUNDING OPTIONS IN THE
STATE AVAILABLE. FOR SAFETY AIMS
TO ACCESS.
SURVIVOR ACCESS TO MEDICAL OF AN
INTRIGUING AND STATEWIDE IS AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE.
WE NEED TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
MORE QUALIFIED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS O PERFORM THESE
VITAL EXAMS.
ENSURE THESE PROFESSIONALS HAVE
ACCESS TO BASIC ADVANCED AND
SPECIALIZED TRAINING AS PROPOSED
BY THIS BILL.
NOT ONLY IN SEXUAL ASSAULT BUT
ALSO IN STRANGULATION DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
IN MY PARTNER VIOLENCE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AN ELDER AND CHILD
ABUSE.
AS HE'S RARELY OCCUR IN
ISOLATION.
RECENT INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED AND PASSED THAT FOCUS
ON THE TESTING OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
KIT FROM DNA ANALYSIS.
WE CANNOT FORGET THAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS ARE BEING COLLECTED
BY THE SAME QUALIFIED HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS.
WHO ARE SEEING AND TREATING
SURVIVORS AND THEIR QUEUE CRISIS?
THE EARLIER SURVIVOR CAN ACCESS
A QUALIFIED FORENSIC EXAMINER
WHO IS APPROPRIATELY TRAINED
EXPERIENCED AND SUPPORTED.
THE HIGHER THE QUALITY OF
EVIDENCE AND THE BETTER THE
OUTCOMES FOR THE PATIENT.
CHANGES PROPOSED BY THIS BILL
ARE NEEDED TO INSURE THAT WE
DELIVER THE BEST RETURN ON
INVESTMENT AND OPTIMIZE THE
RESPONSE THAT SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT BOTH REQUIRE AND
DESERVE.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S MELINDA
WHEELER AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING CAL SAFE AS WELL AS
A FORENSIC NURSE SPECIALIST
WHICH IS A PRIVATELY OWNED
COMPANY LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND ORANGE COUNTY -- I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS WORK FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN WE
HAVE SEEN OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
VICTIMS DURING THAT TIME.
I I STARTED OUT IN THE FIELD AS
A RAPE CRISIS ADVOCATE AND SAW
THAT THERE IS A NEED TO IMPROVE
MEDICAL SERVICES FOR VICTIMS --
HOSPITALS JUST COULD NOT AFFORD
TO HAVE A SPECIALIZED TEAM
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR AN
UNCERTAIN AND NUMBER OF PATIENTS.
WHEN THE VIAL OF BILL WAS PASSED?
AND I WAS PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLIANCE COMMITTEE TO FIND A
WAY TO IMPLEMENT.
OF THE REQUIREMENTS AND AT THAT
TIME WE DEVELOPED A NEW EXAM
FORM AND A PROTOCOL.
BUT WE DID THE BEST WE COULD THE
THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR CAP AT THAT
TIME WAS ACTUALLY A COMPROMISE
THAT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE AND IT WAS TO GET THESE
EXAMS OFF THE GROUND AND GET
THEM STARTED.
WE WERE TO RE EVALUATE HOW IT
WAS GOING IN TWO YEARS NOW IT'S
BEEN SEVEN YEARS.
THE LAW IS COMPLICATED AND
CONFUSING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
EVEN AFTER NUMEROUS TRAININGS.
I NEED TO RE EXPLAIN THIS LAW
EACH AND EVERY TIME A VICTIM
REQUEST THIS TYPE OF EXAM OPTION
AND HAD TO COME OUT AND PICK UP
THE EVIDENCE CAT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY NEED TO PAY
FOR THIS EXAM AT ALL IF THEY DO
NOT GET TO INVESTIGATE THE CRIME.
ONE AGENCY I WORK WITH THE
REFUSES TO PAY ANYTHING IF THEY
CAN I INTERVIEW THE VICTIM.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE IT DID
HAPPEN IN THEIR CITY AND THAT IT
WAS A REAL RATE.
ANOTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IS OKAY WITH PAIN IF I DON'T GO
OVER FIVE OF THESE EXAMS EACH
YEAR BECAUSE THEY HAVE A BUDGET.
POLICE HAVE BUDGETS AND THEY'RE
ALWAYS INADEQUATE.
THESE EXAMS COULD NOT BE DONE AT
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS. FOR YOUR
EXAM TEAMS WHO HAVE SOME EXAM
TEAMS OF HAD TO DECLINE DOING
THEM AT ALL IN CALIFORNIA WILL
BE OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE THOUGHT WHAT IF THESE
TEAMS STRUGGLE TO EVEN SURVIVE.
HOSPITALS IN PLEASE CANNOT KEEP
BEARING THIS BURDEN ALONE.
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS RICK BARTON I'M A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
AND PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SEXUAL ASSAULT
INVESTIGATORS ASSOCIATION.
CSA AYE A STRONGLY URGES SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LUCIA MUCH AROUND HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CRIME
LAB DIRECTORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SIR EAGLE MAN CAL
SAFE TREASURER COORDINATOR FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY SEXUAL ASSAULT
RESPONSE TEAM PROGRAM.
MEMBER OF MONEY COUNTIES
ADMINISTRATION TEAM AND IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BOB JEREMY
HAVE FOR THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MACHEL
SHORES PRESIDENT OF CAL SAFE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FORENSIC NURSING SO CAL CHAPTER.
IN A DIRECTOR OF PALOMAR
FORENSIC HEALTH SERVICES OF SAN
DIEGO AND SUPPORT.
MAURICE REGIS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSE WITH
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE A TWEENER SEWER.
MORNING JOHN FAMILY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL ENCOURAGE
OUR MEMBERS TO DO THE SAME WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR THE
AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE SPONSORS
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS WERE
VERY HAPPY THAT WE CAME TO A
BILL.
THAT WILL WORK FOR EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DELYLAH CLAY ON
BEHALF OF WE'VE A LOCAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND RAPE CRISIS CENTER
REALLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF
THE AUTHOR. TO WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS -- AND WE ARE NOW
NEUTRAL THANK YOU.
GREAT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
RIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION ANY COMMENTS.
RIGHT THEN WE WILL --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN RESPECT
FASTER OF A GREAT WE WILL DO A
ROLL CALL -- AND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU.
MORRELL AYE WIENER -- WE WILL
HAVE IT SAID IT PASSES BUT WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR A
MISSING MEMBER.
AND THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU
YOU'RE WELCOME WE WILL NOW GO TO
ITEM SEVEN AB SIX TWENTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES OF I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A. B..
SIX TWENTY REDUCE SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD.
AND THIS ARISES IS DISTRICT
BATTERY YOUNG MAN DIED
INEXPLICABLY IN THE NIGHT IN THE
EIGHTH DECEMBER DISTRICT OVER
YEARS BACK.
A SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD IS NOT WHOLLY NEW.
BUT IT DOES HAVE A VERY LOW
INCIDENCE ONE POINT.
TWO OCCURRENCES PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN.
ON EARLY IN ANY CASE WHERE YOU
HAVE SUDDEN INFANT DEATH.
OF THE LAW REQUIRES SAID TO
SHOULD BE RETAINED THE PARENTS
BE ADVISED OF THIS. TO SUPPORT
RESEARCH AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
WENT ON AS A YOUNG MAN ACTUALLY
I FIRST ENCOUNTERED SUDDEN
INFANT DEATH SYNDROME BECAUSE IN
MRS BROKAW LOST A BABY.
A WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER IN THE
SEVENTIES -- SO THAT TYPE
REQUIREMENT OR DOES NOT APPLY
WITH RESPECT TO SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
SO BEYOND JUST BEING AN INFANT.
UP TO TWELVE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PASSED ON
A BIPARTISAN BASIS THE SOUTHERN
SPAIN DEATH.
DATA ENHANCEMENT AWARENESS ACT
TO RAISE AWARENESS BETTER SENATE.
OF UNEXPLAINED DEATH FOR
CHILDREN -- OLDER THAN TWELVE
MONTHS.
THIS BILL DEFINED SO DENSE BRAIN
DEATH IN CHARTER STATUTE
REQUIRES CORNERSTONE FOR THE
PARENT OR GUARDIAN.
OF A CHILD WHO DIES OF THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE.
OF TAKING TISSUE SAMPLE FOR FOR
PURPOSES OF FOR THE MASTICATION.
SO IN ESSENCE IT DOVETAILS WITH
THE FEDERAL ACT HAT'S BEEN LOST
SINCE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN I APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO PRESENT THIS BILL HERE
AND I HAVES WITNESSES SUPPORT.
KNOWS THE FAMILY.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIR.
OUR MINDS GARY COOPER AND IN
THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION I'M
REPRESENTING THE FAMILY BECAUSE
AS IT TURNS OUT -- THE WIND
CHILLS LIVED ACROSS THE STREET
BEING WRESTLED ACROSS THE STREET
FROM ME -- SUFFER THIS TRAGEDY
AND AT TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
AND WE'VE ASKED MR COOLEY ON A
COUPLE OF OCCASIONS TO HELP GET
INVOLVED IN THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE.
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS WHEN THE
YOUNG MAN WHO AT THE TIME WAS
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD WENT TO SLEEP
IN THE EVENING HIS PARENTS WENT
TO WAKE HIM UP IN THE MORNING
AND UNFORTUNATELY HIT PASSED
AWAY.
AND WHEN THE POLICE IN THE CHAIR
IN THE CORNER CAME THEY REALLY
DID NOT ADVISE THE PARENTS THAT
IT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO TAKE SOME
TISSUE SAMPLES AND TO DETERMINE
WHAT POSSIBLY COULD BE CAUSING
THIS ULTIMATELY BECAUSE THEY HAD
FRIENDS THAT WERE -- MEDICAL
EXAMINERS AND FRIENDS BECAUSE I
AM INTEREST -- THEY DID THIS AND
THEY'RE STILL STILL NOT 1100%
SURE AS TO WHAT HAPPENED BUT
THEY'RE GETTING A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER.
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION THE
SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH TO
CHILD DACIAN AS MR COOLEY JUST
SAID IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
HAD PRESIDENT OBAMA SIGNED A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. TO
RECOGNIZE SUCH ISSUE DC.
SIDS BEEN AROUND FOR A VERY LONG
TIME S. U. DC IS A FAIRLY NEW --
EVEN THOUGH IT'S BEEN AROUND
IT'S FAIRLY NEW BEING RECOGNIZED
AND SO SIMPLY WHAT THIS BILL
DIES IS PUT IN STATUTE U. DC AND
EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS AND SUGGEST
THAT THE THE CORNERS.
AT TELL THE FAMILY THAT THE
IMPORTANCE OF TISSUE SAMPLES
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO EXPAND THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO DO ANY MORE THAN JUST
PUT IN STATUTE RIGHT NOW.
SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT IS UTC
THE EYES AND WITH THAT I WOULD
TO ASK FOR AND I WROTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MR COOLEY VIEW THAT MOVE THE
MICROPHONE.
FOR GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING ON
MISTER KERRY MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MUCH FLORA BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION -- OF CORNERS WE I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
I'M I DO WANT TO START BY SAYING
THAT -- WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH MR COOLIES OFFICE OVER
SEVERAL YEARS -- ON THIS MATTER
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE ON HIS
OPEN DOOR POLICY AND ON DEPLOYED
YEAH WE HAVE TO BE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH HIS OFFICE
REGARDING THIS ISSUE -- WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT DEATH OF A CHILD
IS OBVIOUSLY VERY TRAUMATIC
SPECIALLY ON WHEN THE REASON IS
UNKNOWN -- BUT WE MASS
RESPECTFULLY CONTINUE OPPOSITION
TO DISPEL ID TO THE WAY THAT THE
BILL IS WRITTEN -- WE DON'T
NECESSARILY OBJECT TO HAD
LETTING A PARENT KNOW THAT IT
TISSUE SAMPLES SHOULD BE TAKEN --
BUT JUST THE DEFINITION OF THE
AT AN UNEXPECTED DEAD IN
CHILDHOOD IN STATUTE IS ATOP THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE.
A RIGHT NOW BOTH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF MEDICAL EXAMINERS
AND TO SOCIETY FOR PEDIATRIC
PATHOLOGY HAVE PROTOCOLS FOR
INVESTIGATING SETS BUT THERE IS
NO SUCH PROTOCOL FOR ADAMS --
FOR DECIDE AN UNEXPECTED THAT IN
CHILDHOOD SO -- THAT WHAT THAT
IS WHAT WE FIND PROBLEMATIC --
WHEN A CORNER OR MEDICAL
EXAMINER SIGNS A DEATH
CERTIFICATE WOULD APPEARS ON THE
CERTIFICATE FOR CAUSE OF DEATH
MASS BE CODED TO A STANDARD --
THAT'S CONTAINED IN THE
INTERNATIONAL CLASSIFICATION OF
DISEASES.
AND ON THIS AT CODY'S USE AND
IT'S CLASSIFIED WEEK TOP CLASS
FINAL TALLY DATA FROM DEATH
CERTIFICATES.
ON THIS -- ICD TEN IS A
COPYRIGHTED BY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WHICH AWESOME
PUBLISHES THE CLASSIFICATION A
DICEY TEN WAS DOUBLE UP
FOLLOWING A THOROUGH --
EVALUATION BY TECHNICAL ADVISORY
PANEL AND EXTENSIVE ADDITIONAL
CONSULTATION WITH PHYSICIAN
GROUPS CLINICAL -- CODERS AND
OTHERS TO ENSURE CLINICAL
ACCURACY AND UTILITY AND SIT
APPEARS ON ICD TEN CODE BUT NO
SUCH CODE APPEARS FOR S. U. DC --
SO IT'S EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC TO
DEFINE S. U. D. C. AS IN YOU
STANDARD IN STATUTE WITHOUT IT
HAVING BEEN VETTED FOR PURPOSES
OF INCLUSION.
ON THE ICD -- TEN SO THIS IS
WHERE -- WE COME APART WITH THE
AUTHOR I WAS WANTING -- TO ASKED
THE CORNERS TO ACT.
I TELL THE PARENTS THAT YOU ARE
ABLE TO TAKE A TWO STAGE YOU
SAMPLED BUT IT'S ANOTHER THING --
TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS WITHOUT ANY KIND OF A A
GUIDELINE IN PLACE -- SO
RESPECTFULLY WE OPPOSE WE ARE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATION SEE IF WE CAN COME
UP WITH SOME KIND OF THAT MEN
MEN MEANT THAT WOULD.
HELP US GOOD NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
THANK YOU.
I KNOW SENATOR MITCHELL MAY HAVE
SOME COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BUT
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SENDER RITUAL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT IT'S
AN EMOTIONAL ISSUE WITH A
PERSONAL ISSUE IN TERMS OF ITS
IMPACT IN A FAMILY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION -- ACCURACY AND
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE BOARD
WITH REGARD TO DEATH
CERTIFICATES IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS IN TERMS OF A RECORD
KEEPING AND DOCUMENTATION.
AND SOUL HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE ISSUES TECHNOLOGY
THAT -- IT'S NOT BEEN DEFINED --
BEYOND WHAT YOU'RE TO BE DOING
STATUTES AGAIN IS IT AND IT DO
YOU THINK THAT DEFINING STATUTE
IS THE APPROPRIATE FIRST STEP TO
THE IMPACT.
THE TRIGGER THE PROCESS SEES
THAT THE OPPONENT IS SUGGESTED
NEED TO TAKE PLACE.
WELL I THINK OF FIRST OPPOSITION
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
MEDICAL EXAMINERS FOR THE
NATIONAL BODY WAS SUPPORTIVE OF
THE RECOGNITION OF THIS IN
FEDERAL STATUTE.
IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WOULD ASSERT THAT TO SAY
IT IS SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH
IN CHILDHOOD IS ITSELF AN
EXPLANATION OF THE CAUSE OF
DEATH.
THE SO I DON'T THINK IT ACTUALLY
ISN'T I I JUST IT IT DOES NOT.
IT DOESN'T SPECIFY WHAT WAS THE
MECHANISM -- THE BIOLOGY THE
MECHANICS THAT PRODUCED THE
DEATH.
SO I DON'T THINK IT IS
EXPLANATORY OF CAUSE OF DEATH.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS ACTUALLY.
TO ENSURE THAT AS WE DO A SUDDEN
INFANT DEATH.
THE PARENTS ARE ALERTED TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF TAKING A TISSUE
SAMPLE.
YOU KNOW THIS IS YOU HAVE TO PUT
YOURSELF IN.
YOUR LIFE IS NORMAL.
AND THEN SUDDENLY YOU REALIZE
YOUR CHILD IS NEVER GONNA COME
WALKING DOWN THE HALLWAY TO
COOLEY I GET THAT AND ON THE
EMOTIONAL LEVEL I'M WITH YOU BUT
MY POINT AS DOES YOUR BILL GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND.
THE FIRST STEP OF EMPOWERING
PARENTS WITH THE INFORMATION
ASKING FOR TISSUE SAMPLE I GET
THE IMPRESSION OF MY GUYS AND
LEAVE THE LANGUAGE OF YOUR BILL.
DANGEROUSLY GOES BEYOND THAT
FIRST IMPORTANT STEP AND I DON'T
BELIEVE IT DOES DO THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE IT.
FORCES A CATEGORY OF EXPLANATION
AS TO WHAT WAS THE CAUSE OF
DEATH.
AS ASCERTAINED BY THE BEST
EFFORTS OF THE CORNER THE
SHERIFF WHOEVER THAT WOULD BE
MEDICAL EXAMINER I THANK YOU
[inaudible]
I'M SURE.
SUMMIT COOLEY -- WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF MEDICAL EXAMINERS
AND THE?
SOCIETY FOR PEDIATRIC PATHOLOGY
TO GET THEM TO ADD THIS CATEGORY.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL I
DO NOT KNOW.
I MEAN THEY SUPPORTED THE BILL
IDENTIFYING THIS AS A PHENOMENON.
THAT WAS WORTHY OF FURTHER
RESEARCH.
WHICH PROMPTED THE BIPARTISAN
ENACTMENT.
OF THE BILL SO IT PROMOTES
RESEARCH.
AND THESE THIS TYPE OF NOTICE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ONE POINT TWO
INCHES PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN WILL PROVIDE A FUND OF
REESE.
RESEARCH A BOWL TISSUE SAMPLES
FUNDING ALIGNS WITH THE NATIONAL
INITIATIVE -- AND BUT I DO NOT
KNOW MORE THAN I MISTER COOPER
DO YOU HAVE ANY OBSERVATIONS ON
FOR SOME OF THE BASICALLY WHEN A
ACTUAL BOND.
THROUGH THE CHAIR ON THE MANAGER.
SHARE MADAM CHAIR WITH EACH YEAR --
BASICALLY THE NATIONALS --
THREATEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH
COALITION -- THEY HAVE WORKED ON
A NATIONAL LEVEL WITH MEDICAL
EXAMINERS TO TRY TO INCREASE THE
DATA COLLECTION.
YES -- IN ANSWER TO A SENATOR
MITCHELL'S CONCERN AND TO
SENATOR -- MORE LAX CONCERN I I
DON'T KNOW AS MR COOLEY STATE I
DON'T KNOW QUITE YET WHETHER
THEY'RE GETTING READY TO
ESTABLISH CODES AS SHE IS.
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CORONER'S -- SUGGESTED I DON'T
KNOW THAT BUT I DO KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE ESTABLISHED A LARGE
DATA COLLECTION FACILITY AND
WITH.
DEALING WITH SO AS TO THE C.
CENSUS IS TAKEN EFFECT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN SINCE THE
BILL WAS SIGNED IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
SMITH FULLER THEN WHAT IS YOUR
ORGANIZATION DOING TO ADD THIS
IS A CATEGORY.
YOU MAY RESPOND.
I THANK YOU -- WERE UP WE ARE
WORKING TOWARDS I MEAN I DON'T
KNOW I CAN'T ANSWER WHAT'S BEING
DONE NATIONALLY AND I CAN ANSWER
A WHAT'S BEING DONE AS AN
ASSOCIATION TO WORK ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. TO MAKE SURE
THIS GETS ON THE LIST -- BUT BUT
AGAIN WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO DOING
THIS ISSUE SAMPLE BUT WE ARE
OPPOSED UNTIL THIS GETS ON THE
NATIONAL REGISTRY WE CAN'T.
ON THE WAY WE CO THINGS WE JUST.
IT WILL NOT GIVE US THE ABILITY
TO APPROPRIATELY CODE AND DO THE
JOB THAT WE NEED TO DO SO I MEAN
I'M HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE WOULD WHAT'S BEING DONE
ON THE STATE LEVEL TO WORK WITH
THE NATIONAL LEVEL. TO MAKE SURE
THIS GETS ON THIS ODD GETS A
COATING THAT IS NEEDED.
GREAT THE NUMBER IS STILL THE
FLOOR.
MR COOLEY I'M JUST CURIOUS IF
PERHAPS WE COULD DO A RESOLUTION.
TO TO TO GET THE ICD TEN MANUAL
UPDATED FOR THIS CATEGORY.
GET SOMETHING AT LEAST ON THEIR
RADAR. TO GET THE BALL MOVING
WELL I THINK YOU COULD DO THAT
MAY I THINK THE YOU HAVE AN
ISSUE THAT.
SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD.
DOES NOT EXPLAIN THE MECHANISM I
AT THIS POINT.
OF SUDDEN INFANT DEATH SYNDROME
IS AN IDENTIFIABLE MEDICAL
BECAUSE THIS IS AN AREA WHERE IT
IS NOT UNDERSTOOD THE MECHANISM
FOR NOT UNDERSTOOD.
SO I A IT SEEMS. TO ME PREMATURE
THAT YOU WOULD MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF IDENTIFYING THIS AS
AN ACTUAL BECAUSE A HERE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE DO THEY RADIS
RADIS CHILDREN HOSPITAL IS DOING
RESEARCH IN THIS AREA.
THE BOSTON CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
DOING RESEARCH IN THIS AREA.
THAT IS IN SUING FROM THE
FEDERAL LACK FROM [inaudible]
TWENTY FOURTEEN ON BUT UNTIL
[inaudible]
OUR I DON'T KNOW HOW A MEDICAL
EXAMINER CORONER SHERIFF WOULD
DISPLACING WAS REALLY -- WHETHER
A RESOLUTION WOULD ALSO YOU
COULD CERTAIN ALL I MEAN I I
RESOLUTION WOULD BE COMMENDABLE
TO KIND OF SPUR THAT WORK.
THIS IS ON THE ISSUE OF CAN WE
ESTABLISH A ROUTINE IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN THIS FACT
PATTERN SHOWS UP.
THAT PARENTS WHO ARE IN TRAUMA
TO A PARTY I DO THINK WE KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE THE BILL DOES I
THINK WE TO FOR QUESTIONS WITH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IN YOUR
MORAL.
OKAY SO -- WHEN SECOND BEFORE
CALLING SENATOR JACKSON I JUST
WANNA MAKE ONE QUICK EXPLANATION
SO THE -- OUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTSTO ANALYZE THE BILL
WE OF COURSE I NOTED IMMEDIATELY
THAT THIS BILL WOULD BEEN VETOED.
A IDENTICAL BILL IT'S BEEN
VETOED TWICE AND SO I ASKED THE
CONSULTANTS.
TO TAKE A VERY GOOD LOOK AT
WHETHER IT DID GO BEYOND --
CODES AS WAS SUGGESTED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND WHETHER -- IT DID
AS SIMPLY AS WAS DESCRIBED MAKE
THE SUGGESTION OF THE TISSUE
SAMPLES AND IF YOU AND NOTE ON
PAGE TWO OF THE ACTUAL TEXT OF
THE BILL.
AND YOU READ IT SERVICE IT'S
BASICALLY PRETTY SHORT IT DOES
ONLY THAT AND DOES NOT CHANGE
CODES.
AND SO BECAUSE IT DOESN'T GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND EVEN THOUGH YES
IT HAS BEEN VETOED -- I WAS
WILLING -- TO RECOMMENDING AYE
VOTE ON IT SO I JUST WANTED TO
EXPLAIN THAT AND SENATOR JACKSON
GO AHEAD.
YEAH FOR VERY BRIEFLY -- OF THIS
IS A LIMITED SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES ONE POINT TWO OUT
OF EVERY -- HUNDRED THOUSAND I
JUST WONDER THOUGH IF.
IT THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO GET
THIS INTO CODE BACK IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN OF BUT THAT
HASN'T HAPPENED -- I WONDER IF
BY PASSING THIS BILL AND HAVING
IT SIGNED INTO LAW THAT MIGHT
ALSO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS.
I WOULD SUSPECT THAT THE IF WE
DO NOTHING THEN NOTHING'S GOING
TO HAPPEN -- SO IT'S ON THAT
BASIS THAT I I WILL MOVE THE
BILL AND HOPE THAT WE CAN GET
SOME.
CLARITY IN SOME CLOSURE ON THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED HERE I THINK
THEY'RE LEGITIMATE EVEN IF
THEY'RE LIMITED.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
CAUSE ENORMOUS OF PEOPLE IN THE
WHOLE PROCESS BUT OF THE PERHAPS
IF WEEK PASSES AND IT BECOMES
LAW WILL GET THE ATTENTION OF
THOSE WHO CAN CO THIS FAIRLY
QUICKLY I SUSPECT SO WITH THAT
AND MOVE THE BILL.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION WE SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY MAY CLOSE.
RIGHT SHALL WE DO A ROLL CALL.
MEASURES THE PAST TWO TWO DASH.
SKINNER FIVE SKINNER I'M MORE
LOCKED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
HIGH.
MORALE HIGH WIENER -- WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR
MISSING MEMBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL NOW GO TO SEE SOME OF
THE COLOR IS NOT HERE SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ITEM.
ELEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
THIS IS AB
.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO INSURERS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO PROMOTE PUBLIC TRUST AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY PERMITS
AN EMPLOYER TO REQUEST ARREST
INFORMATION OF A PEACE OFFICER
OR APPLICANT FOR A PEACE OFFICER
POSITION.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALSO PERMITS
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE AGENCIES TO
ACCESS THE ARREST RECORDS OF A
NON SWORN EMPLOYEE APPLICANT FOR
A POSITION WITHIN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AGENCY HOWEVER.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT PERMIT
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE AGENCIES TO
REQUEST ARREST INFORMATION F A
NON SWORNEMPLOYEE FOR A NON
SWORN EMPLOYEE POSITION.
ALLOWING CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AGENCIES TO ACCESS SUCH
INFORMATION ONLY IN CASES WHERE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS SPECIFIC
DUTIES RELATE TO THE COLLECTION
OF ANALYSIS OR OF EVIDENCE OR
PROPERTY OR DIRECTLY RELATE TO
THE CRIMINAL OFFENDERS OF THEIR
RECORDS.
IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURING PUBLIC
TRUST IN OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
I WILL HAVE -- WITCHER'S
PERMISSION MY WITNESS THE SELF
INTRODUCE CERTAINLY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH OR ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ON SPONSORS OF
ASSEMBLY BILL AT THIRTEEN
SEVENTY TWO ARE WE WANTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON FOR
AUTHORING JUST LEGISLATION.
ON A WE UNDERSTAND THAT HAVING
ETHICAL AND CONSCIENTIOUS
PERSONAL IS PIVOTAL TO SAFEGUARD
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR COURT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM NO
MATTER TO RANK OR TITLE -- SO
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
CONSISTING TRUSTWORTHY
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THEY MUST HAVE
NECESSARY MEANS TO REQUEST AND
RECEIVE ARREST RECORDS -- FOR
CERTAIN NON SWORN EMPLOYEES ON
THIS PROCESS ENSURES EQUITY
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE HAVE
SPONSORED THIS LEGISLATION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
VOTE I AND THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I'M.
RIGHT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE SENATOR BRADFORD YES THINK
ABOUT YOUR I'M JUST CURIOUS IS
YOUR CURRENT PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
THAT REQUIRES HIS BILL AND WHAT
ARE YOU TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE --
THANK YOU I'M YES ARE THERE HAVE
BEEN A CERTAIN -- COUNTIES WHERE
AT THEIR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NON
SWORN FOR EXAMPLE CORRECTIONAL
STAFF WHO IS ON MANAGING JAILS
AT THE HAVE BEEN ARRESTED.
AND THEN WHEN THE EMPLOYING
AGENCY ASK FOR THAT ARREST
RECORD YOUR TOLD THAT UNDER
DESPITE YOU KILL LABOR CODE FOR
THIRTY SEVEN THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO ASK FOR THAT PERSON'S
ARREST RECORDS.
BECAUSE THERE WERE PROHIBITED BY
LAW -- SO AND THEN -- THERE'S
ALSO BEEN AGENCIES WHERE ON
THERE HAD BEEN DISPATCHERS WHERE
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED ON DO YOU AYE
CHARGES I WENT EMPLOYING AT IN A
DIFFERENT COUNTY AND WHAT THE
EMPLOYING AGENCY.
I REQUEST THOUGH DOES ARREST
RECORDS THEY'VE BEEN TOLD THAT
THEY ARE PROHIBITED BY LAW I
NOTICE LABOR CODE TO ASK FOR HIS
ARREST RECORDS SO THEREFORE DEBT --
EMPLOYER IS LEFT OUT WITHOUT ANY
THEY CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE
SITUATION INVESTIGATED TO SEE
WHETHER THOSE CHARGES ACTUALLY
OCCURRED IN THE EXAMPLE OF THE
CORRECTIONAL STAFF -- THE PERSON
WAS ACCUSED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SO IS VERY PROBLEMATIC TO HAVE A
CORRECTIONAL STAFF WHO'S IN
CHARGE OF VERY VULNERABLE
POPULATION IN THE JAILS ON TO BE
CHARGED WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
YET THE EMPLOYER CAN ACCESS THE
RIVER.
THE REST WRECKERS TO ASCERTAIN
WHETHER AT IT HAPPEN OR DID NOT
HAPPEN WHAT COURSE OF ACTION
SHOULD BE TAKEN.
I GOT IT AND I GUESS MY CONCERN
IS [inaudible]
JUST.
BASED ON A TORN AND
DEMONSTRATION THAT WE JUST SAW
OUR EARLIER THIS MORNING WHICH
IS.
RIGHT OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL OF
FORTY FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT AND FROM
PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
ALREADY COMPLETED HER SENTENCE
IN THE FACT THAT SOMEONE HAS
BEEN ARRESTED -- DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THIS IS A
PATTERN OR SHOULD LEAD TO
UNEMPLOYMENT ARE LOSING THEIR
JOBS SO.
I'M JUST REALLY -- CONCERNED
HERE AND WHO'S GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THIS AND YEAH SO I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
WHAT CONCERNS SENATOR MITCHELL
HOUSING THEN PERHAPS THE AUTHOR
AND WITNESS OF APPROPRIATE CAN
RESPOND GO AHEAD SIR?
THANK YOU I THINK RIGHT CONCERNS
ARE VERY SIMPLE WHAT TROUBLES ME
IS IN THE EXAMPLES YOU GAVE YOU
TALKED ABOUT PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
CHARGED.
AND WE ALL ARE CLEAR THAT AN
ARREST.
SO WILL BE IN CHARGE AND A
CONVICTION ARE THREE DIFFERENT
SENT OUT ON THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SPECTRUM.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
ALL THE WAY BACK TO WIN A REST.
THAT MAY LEAD TO ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
MAY LEAD ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IT
GIVES ME GREAT CONCERN -- YOU
SAID SOMEONE HAD BEEN CHARGED
WITH THE NEXT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HE DID NOT SAY WHETHER NOT DID
BEEN CONVICTED.
BUT A THE REST AND A CHARGE YOU
TO SEPARATE STEPS.
AND SO IF YOUR BILL TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN CHARGED WITH
CERTAIN CRIMES I MIGHT FEEL
DIFFERENTLY BUT WHEN YOU
CONSIDER -- THE NUMBER OF
ARRESTS THAT OCCUR ACROSS THE
STATE THAT LEAD TO NO FURTHER
ACTION FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S ALARMING THAT AS WE HAVE
WORKED FOR YEARS AROUND THE
ISSUE OF BAND BOB BAN THE BOX
THAT WE WOULD TAKE A STEP
BACKWARDS QUITE FRANKLY. TO OPEN
THIS UP -- TO ARREST THAT YOU
DON'T EVEN.
NEARLY DEFINE ARRESTS FOR WHAT.
I COULD BE ARRESTED FOR GAVE
ENGAGE IN CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE
MANY OF US HAVE -- WHICH SHOULD
HAVE NO BEARING ON MY ABILITY TO
TO PERFORM ANY PROFESSIONAL
FUNCTION.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY I JUST
THINK IT'S YOU'VE PAINTED TOO
BROAD A BRUSH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRATION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND AND YOU CAN ALSO
HAVE YOUR WITNESS EXCUSE.
I THANK YOU I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPACT ALL OF
THE LABOR CODE THAT'S IN THIS
BILL FOR THIRTY SEVEN STANDS AT
IT AS IT IS RIGHT NOW WE ARE
JUST NARAL LEAD.
ON TALKING ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AGENCY AND WITHIN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCY WE ARE
NARROWLY FOCUSING ON THOSE NON
SWORN EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE.
VERY PRETTY [inaudible]
PARTICULAR POSITIONS WHO HANDLE
EVIDENCE AND DO FORENSIC WORK.
THAT THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT NOTHING
IN THE BILL WOULD AFFECT ANYONE
WHO'S TRYING TO APPLY FOR A JOB.
OR WHO IS CURRENTLY EMPLOYED IN
ANY POSITION.
THIS IS A CLARIFICATION IT WOULD
AFFECT SOMEONE APPLYING FOR THE
JOB IF THEY ARE IN THE CATEGORY
THAT YOU'RE NEARLY EXEMPTING
CORRECT.
CORRECT RIGHT NOW RIGHT ALL
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE POWER TO
WELL RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW WHEN WE
EMPLOYEE SOMEONE THAT ALREADY
EXIST WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS TO ARREST RECORDS.
THAT ALREADY IS UNDER CURRENT
LAW WE'RE NOT CHANGING THAT.
SO IF THEIR SWORN OFFICER BUT
NOT THIS CATEGORY YOU KNOW NON
SWORN EMPLOYEES AS WELL THAT
THAT'S ALSO IN THIS CATEGORY
THERE ARE SOME NORRIS NON SWORN
EMPLOYEES OR APPLICANTS.
YES APPLICANTS FOR NON SWORN
EMPLOYEES.
UNDER CERTAIN CODE ARE CURRENTLY
WE ARE CURRENTLY ABLE TO ACCESS
TO ARREST RECORDS IS ONCE THAT
THEY'RE HIRED IS THE PROBLEM
THEN WE CANNOT GO BACK.
I'M NOT THAT WE GO BACK THAT IF
SOMETHING WERE TO HAPPEN WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO DO IT.
IS UNDER THIRTY ONE A ONE
SENATOR MITCHELL AND SO -- SINCE
IT'S BEEN SO NARROWLY DEFINED AS
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED -- WHY NOT
DIDN'T NEARLY TO FIND THE NATURE
OF THE ARREST?
WE'RE CERTAINLY WE'RE HAPPY TO
LOOK INTO THAT.
SIMILAR GRAYSON TO JOIN AT
SOMETHING.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT -- AS
WAS ALREADY STATED THAT IT
ALREADY EXIST TO BE ABLE TO PULL
ARREST RECORDS FOR THOSE THAT
ARE APPLY.
IT'S ONCE THEY'VE BEEN HIRED FOR
NON SWORN EMPLOYEES.
AND THOUGH THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS TO ACTUALLY BUILD A
BRIDGE OF TRUST BETWEEN A PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCY AND THE COMMUNITY.
TO BE ABLE TO SAY WELL.
I SEE YOUR REACTION -- BUT TO BE
ABLE TO SEE WELL TO BE ABLE TO
SAY THAT -- IF WE HAVE SOMEONE
IN A SENSITIVE -- POSITION THAT
IS DIRECTLY RELATED -- TO THE
ANALYSIS OF EVIDENCE OF THE
COLLECTION OF EVIDENCE OR
PROPERTY OR DIRECTLY RELATED TO
SUCH ACTIVITIES AS APPREHENSION
PROSECUTION ADJUDICATION
INCARCERATION CORRECTION OF
CRIMINAL OFFENDERS OR COLLECTION
STORAGE DISSEMINATION.
OF USAGE OF CRIMINAL OFFENDER
RECORD INFORMATION THAT IF
SOMEONE IS ARRESTED THAT THAT
AGENCY CAN LOOK INTO THAT BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT AFFECTS
THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
IT JUST SIMPLY MEANS THAT THERE
IS AN AWARENESS THAT -- THE
AGENCY HAS TAKEN TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK INTO IT AND INVESTIGATE --
NO DECISION IS MADE EVERYBODY IS
ABSOLUTELY -- WORTHY OF DUE
PROCESS AND JUST BECAUSE THERE
WAS AN ARREST DOESN'T MEAN THERE
MAY BE IT MAY BE A CONVICTION
MAY NOT.
BUT JUST SO THAT THE AGENCY THAT
THEY'RE WORKING FOR BECAUSE OF
THE SENSITIVITY OF THEIR
POSITION THE AGENCY CAN ALSO BE
ABLE TO STATE THAT THEY AS WELL
ARE AWARE.
AND ARE TAKING MEASURES TO LOOK
INTO IT.
DARKNESS OF THE NATURE OF THE
ARREST.
WELL I I THINK THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT -- THE OUR
WITNESSES ALSO STATED WE WOULD
DEFINITELY BE INTERESTED IN
LOOKING INTO -- YOUR CONCERN
THERE ABSOLUTELY.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT IF THE
PERSONS THAT WHOM YOU WOULD BE
EXPANDING ITS TO WORK TO BE
CONVICTED.
THE EMPLOYER WOULD BE NOTIFIED.
SO THIS IS SOLELY ON AN ARREST
IN OUR ASSUMPTION IS THAT
WHETHER ARRESTED OR NOT ONE IS
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY
ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S IT IS TROUBLING I HADN'T
THOUGHT ABOUT SOME OF THE
ASPECTS THAT.
GUEST -- EMERGED IN THIS
CONVERSATION THAT.
IN WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL OF BIAS. FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN -- LOTS OF
RESEARCH THAT SHOWS IT WHEN YOU
WALK INTO THE COURTROOM.
IF YOU ARE THE INDIVIDUAL YOU
KNOW BEING TRIED IF YOU ARE IN
STREET CLOTHES.
MEANING IF YOU'RE NOT IN SAY AN
ORANGE JUMPSUIT.
OR LET'S PUT IT THE DIFFERENT
WAY IF YOU'RE IN THE ORANGE
JUMPSUIT.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF YOUR
CONVICTION GOES WAY UP I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT PERCENTAGE BUT IT
DID SIGNIFICANT -- SO WE KNOW
THAT CERTAIN INFORMATION WHETHER --
INTENTIONAL OR NOT AFFECTS OUR
PERCEPTION DâN ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S SO THE ARREST MAY
HAVE MAY.
BE AN YOU KNOW LEAD TO NO
CONVICTION IN YET WHAT DOES THE
EMPLOYER DO WITH THAT
INFORMATION SO I THINK SENATOR
MITCHELL'S POINT THAT.
IF THE ARREST WERE.
WHAT WERE IN RELATING TO AREAS
THAT?
MAY -- INDICATE THE SOME --
CONCERNS ABOUT THE THE FXE OF
THAT PERSON HANDLING FOR EXAMPLE
EVIDENCE OR SOMETHING PERHAPS.
THAT THAT'S A DIFFERENT STORY.
NINE DEAD.
LADY THE CATEGORY OF THINGS ONE
CAN BE ARRESTED FOR IS QUITE
QUITE PROPERTIES RIGHT AND I I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND MADAM CHAIR
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT MANDATING THAT
AN EMPLOYER -- HAS TO COME TO
SOME RESOLUTION THAT IMPACTS A
PERSON'S EMPLOYMENT MAKE IT
NEGATIVELY.
ALL IT SIMPLY DOES IS ALLOW THE
EMPLOYER TO HAVE AN AWARENESS
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING IN
IT THAT WOULD PREVENT THE
EMPLOYER FROM.
IMPACTING THE EMPLOYEE NEGATIVE
I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE WOULD
ALREADY BE -- EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
PROTECTIONS IN EXISTENCE ALREADY --
THIS IS NOT ABOUT TAKING AWAY
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS THIS IS
ABOUT ALLOWING.
ESPECIALLY IN THE SENSITIVITY --
IN THE AREA OF SENSITIVITY THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY AND TRUST WITH THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
JUST MAKING SURE THAT THINGS ARE
ABOUT FOUR TRANSPARENT.
AND THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
THAT ARE SERVING -- TO SERVING A
CAPACITY WITH THIS WARNER NON
SWORN ARE SERVING IN A WAY -- TO
PROTECT ND UPHOLD OUR TRUST
WITH THE COMMUNITY [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE ARE HOPING TO BE ASKED TO GO
TO COMMITTEE OKAY -- WE DO HAVE
A MOTION HOWEVER WE DO HAVE TIME
BEFORE THE ARE DEADLINE AND I
WONDERED IF YOU WOULD BE WILLING
TO HOLD THE BILL SO THAT WE
MIGHT DISCUSS.
IF THERE ARE POSSIBLE.
THAT YOU WOULD BE COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT MIGHT ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED [inaudible]
YES PLEASE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M FOR EXAMPLE WHAT -- AGAIN I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS WOULD ADDRESS
ALL THE MEMBERS CONCERNS BUT AS
THEY CAN COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE
RACE THAT.
THERE MAY BE -- YEAH POSSIBLE TO
AMEND FOR EXAMPLE TO CRIMES --
OF MORAL TURPITUDE WHICH WOULD --
BE DOES THAT RELATE TO
DISHONESTY WHICH THEN OF COURSE
IS VERY RELEVANT TO WHAT YOU
WERE DESCRIBING.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY UM I THINK
I WILL I WILL FOLLOW YOUR
DIRECTION ON THIS AND HOLD THE
BILL -- WITH THE COMMITMENT THAT --
WE WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
WORK WITH COMMITTEE STAFF IN USE
YEAH SHARE AND THEN ALSO -- IF I
WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVETIME WITH
A SENATORS MITCHELL AND AND
BRADFORD -- ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AS WELL AND TO COME UP
WITH SOME IDEAS TO IMPROVE THE
BILL.
I THINK CERTAINLY THE BENEFIT OF
THIS HEARING BEING EARLY IN THE
PROCESS IS THAT WE HAVE SOME
TIME AND WE DON'T HAVE.
TO DELAY IT BEYOND NECESSARILY
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION
[inaudible]
SO -- I APPRECIATE.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO DO SO WE
WILL HOLD IT FOR ONE OF THE
HEARINGS BEFORE THE DEADLINE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- I AM GOING TO HAND
THE MIKE OVER TO MY VICE CHAIR I
HAVE TO GO PERCENT A BILL.
IN -- THE BNP COMMITTEE.
BUT THE NEXT ITEM WOULD BE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIOUS AND
CENTER MORE LIKE YOU ARE NOW IN
TURKEY -- EVEN [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
BECAUSE GERMAN.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS I BRING BEFORE SENATORS
I BRING BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINETY THREE THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL IN RESPONSE THE
OVERWHELMING CALL FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS -- IN THE TWENTY
SECOND AGRICULTURE DISTRICT TO
STOP THE SALE OF GUNS AND
AMMUNITION.
AT OUR FIRST OUR LOCAL
FAIRGROUNDS.
AS WE WERE JUST COMMITTEE ARE NO
DOUBT AWARE THE PLAGUE OF GUN
VIOLENCE IS VERY REAL -- IN
EVERY CORNER OF OUR STATE --
UNLIKE OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY -- MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
HERE TODAY TO OFFER MORE THEIR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS WE ARE HERE
FOR ACTION -- AS WITH MANY OF
YOUR DISTRICTS MY CONSTITUENTS
HAVE AN ARE NOT WAITING FOR
OTHERS TO TAKE ACTION LAST
YEAR'S -- DEL MAR INSISTS ON A
BEACH AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
ACROSS AN EAGLE COUNTY PETITION
THE DEL MAR FAIR BOARD A STATE
AGENCY -- THE GOVERNS THE DEL
MAR FAIRGROUNDS TO STOP ITS
COMPLICITY IN PROFITING OFF THE
SALE OF GUNS AND AMMUNITION. TO
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS THEY HEARD US
LOUD AND CLEAR IN RESPONSE THE
FAIR BOARD AGREED WITH THE
COMMUNITY IN VOTED INSTRUCTED
STAFF TO EXPLORE POLICY TO PHASE
OUT STATE SANCTIONED GUN SHOWS.
THE BOARD INSTRUCTED STAFF TO
EXPLORE GUN SAFETY AND
EDUCATIONAL EVENTS FOR GUNS AND
AMMUNITION WOULD NOT BE SOLD.
ABROAD LIKE OTHER CO AGRICULTURE
DISTRICT BOARDS ARE BORED
LISTENING HEEDED THE CALL TO
EXPLORE THE PROHIBITION OF GUNS
AND AMMUNITION FOR SALE.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS NOTES THE WORK
TO LIMIT GUN SHOWS IS CURRENTLY.
ON HOLD AS THE BORDER WASTE
DISPOSITION OF A LEGAL CHALLENGE
BY THE GUN SHOW VENDOR.
OR NO FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT
THIS GUN SHOW VENDOR CROSSROADS
OF THE WEST HAS FILED SUIT
AGAINST THE BOARD ACTION DESPITE
BEING UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF USTICE.
THE DOJ IS CURRENTLY REVIEWING
THE CERTIFICATE OF ELIGIBILITY
FOR ONE OF THE PROMOTERS OF THE
SHOW GIVEN AN APPARENT FELONY
RECORD.
MEMBERS ABA NINETY THREE THE
DISTRICT BILL THIS IS
LEGISLATION ONLY IMPACTS THE
FIRE ARMS THAT ARE SOLD IN
SEVENTY TO ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN
DOES NOT AFFECT THE ABILITY OF
OTHER AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS
TO SELL WEAPONS.
ON THEIR PROPERTY I HAVE DOZENS
OF MY CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE
TRAVELED TO SACRAMENTO TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
SHARED A COMMUNITY PRIORITY.
I HOPE THE HEED THE CALL OF
THESE FOLKS AND OUT ALLOW US TO
IN GUN SHOWS ONCE AND FOR ALL I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE WAS IN SHARP -- THE
CO FOUNDER OF NEVER AGAIN
CALIFORNIA AND KELLY HARLESS
MEMBER OF THIS LONG BEACH CITY
COUNCIL TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THE COMMISSION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME IS ROSEANNE SHARP AND I
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
AB EIGHT NINETY THREE AND ASK
FOR YOUR VOTES I RESIDE IN THE
SEVENTY EIGHTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
I AM THE FOUNDER OF NEVER AGAIN
CA OUR NAME IS OUR MISSION.
AND IT COMES FROM THE STUDENTS
AT PARKLAND GOVERNOR NEWSOME
ASKED FOR YOUR VOTES IN FAVOR OF
AB EIGHT NINETY THREE WHEN HE
STATED.
IF CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
PERMIT THE SALE OF FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION ON STATE OWNED
PROPERTY WE ARE SENDING A SIGNAL
THAT WE VALUE THE SALE OF
FIREARMS.
ABOVE THE LIVES OF AMERICANS THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS ASKED FOR YOUR VOTES IN
FAVOR OF AB EIGHT NINETY THREE
BECAUSE IT BELIEVES THAT WHILE
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION.
IN PASSING COMMONSENSE LAWS.
COMMUNITY STILL FEEL THREATENED
BY THE MAGNITUDE OF FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION PRESENT AT GUN SHOWS
THE CITY COUNCILS OF DAHLE
MARCELLINA BEACH AND ENCINITAS
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE IN THE
RESOLUTIONS THAT THEY PASSED IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT NINETY THREE MEMBERS OF
THE DEL BAR DEL MAR FAIR BOARD
THE TWENTY SECOND THE AA NEED
YOUR VOTES NOW.
WHEN THE FAIR BOARD UNCOVERED
VIOLATIONS THEY SUSPENDED GUN
SHOWS NOW THEY WAIT FOR YOUR
VOTES? TO MAKE THE WILL SUSPEND
OUR PERMANENTLY AND WILL CONFIRM
THAT THE PUBLIC POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA IS LIVES MATTER MORE
THAN PROFIT.
THESE CALLS FOR ACTION ARE NOT
NEW THE ONLY THING THAT IS NEW
IS SINCE WE TESTIFIED ON MARCH
TWENTY SIX AT THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
THERE WAS ANOTHER ATTEMPTED MASS
SHOOTING ON APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH
AT THE POWER A SYNAGOGUE WHICH
RESULTED IN THE DEATH OF LAURIE
K..
AN INJURY TO THE RABBIS AND
SEVERAL.
ATTENDING THE SERVICE INCLUDING
A CHILD.
ONLY MRS KAY'S BRAVERY AND A JAM
TO GUN FORDED ANOTHER MASS
SHOOTING. FOR SAN DIEGO COUNTY
RESIDENTS WE CALL ON YOU TODAY
TO TELL OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
NEVER AGAIN WILL THE STATE OWNED
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS.
PROMOTE AND PROFIT FROM THE SALE
AND PROLIFERATION OF FIREARMS
AND AMMUNITION.
NEVER AGAIN CA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S KELLY
HARLESS I AM A COUNCIL MEMBER
AND SELANNE BEACH A CITY THAT'S
ADJACENT TO THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS.
IN THIS CAPACITY I SERVE ON THE
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COMMITTEE AS
A LIAISON BETWEEN MY CITY AND
THE FAIR GROUNDS.
IN ADDITION TO BEING A COUNCIL
MEMBER I AM A MOTHER.
AND I'VE SEENFIRST HAND HOW THE
THREAT OF GUN VIOLENCE AFFECTS
OUR YOUTH IN SCHOOLS.
DID YOU KNOW THAT IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE DEATH
RATE FROM GUNS SIR PASSED THE
DEATH RATE FROM CAR CRASHES
[inaudible]
IT'S TRUE.
AS YOU AND I LAY AWAKE AT NIGHT
WAITING FOR OUR YOUNG TEEN
DRIVERS TO RETURN HOME.
IT'S HARD TO GRASP THIS NEW
REALITY.
THAT IT'S MORE LIKELY TO DIE
FROM A GUNSHOT.
BEEN IN A CAR ACCIDENT.
BUT OUR KIDS GET IT.
IT'S PART OF THEIR LIVES NOW.
IT'S LIKE BUCKLING ON A SEAT
BELT.
LESS THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AFTER THE PARKLAND SHOOTING MY
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND I
HAD TO DRIVE PAST THE FLASHING
MARQUEE AT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS.
ADVERTISING THE UPCOMING GUN
SHOW.
SHORTLY THEREAFTER I WATCHED MY
DAUGHTER STAND BRAVELY IN FRONT
OF THE FAIR BOARD.
SURROUNDED BY A CROWD OF VERY
LOCAL.
AND ARE A FOLKS. TO TALK ABOUT
HER EXPERIENCE.
SHE SHARED HOW SHE HAD DRAFTED A
STEP BY STEP SKATE PLAN.
FROM EACH OF HER HIGH SCHOOL
CLASSROOMS.
SHE TALKED ABOUT SCHOOL FIRE
DRILLS.
AND HER SCHOOLMATES BEING AFRAID
TO LEAVE THE CLASSROOM. FOR FEAR
IT WAS A RUSE.
FULLER THEM OUT.
PRIVATELY SHE SHARED WITH ME THE
NAMES OF HER FRIENDS
[inaudible]
FELLOW CLASSMATES.
THE STRONGEST KIDS THE STRONGEST%
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD CHILDREN.
WHO HAD BEEN ASSIGNED THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF BARRICADING
THE DOORS WITH SCHOOL FURNITURE?
IN CASE OF AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
THAT'S WHY STOPPING THE GUN
SHOWS AND ENDING THE SALE OF
GUNS AND AMMUNITION.
AT THE FAIR GROUNDS WAS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF MY CAMPAIGN.
BELIEVE ME IT'S A MESSAGE THAT
RESONATES STRONGLY.
AND IT'S GETTING LOUDER BY THE
DAY.
WE DON'T WANT OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
CONTRIBUTING TO THE
PROLIFERATION OF GUNS.
BY SELLING FIRE ARMS ON STATE
OWNED PROPERTY.
PLEASE GET CALIFORNIA OUT OF THE
GUN SHOW BUSINESS AND PASS THIS
BILL.
WILL GO.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BUT WE CAN
STILL GET OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN IN OPPOSITION
WHENEVER DISCUSSION GO AHEAD
MORE NON CHURCH ON THE CLAY
ABOUT THE CITY EVEN SENATORS
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE SENSIBLE
MEASURE. TWENTY SEVEN QUICK
BEARSTED ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT
AND SOLIDARITY WITH OUR SO CAL A
COMBINE THOSE PENSION ACTIVISTS
THANK.
IN THE COMMENTS ON THE BEACH
FOUNDING MEMBER OF NEVER AGAIN
CALIFORNIA.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I RARE SHARK DEL MAR A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF NEVER AGAIN AND I
SUPPORT AB EIGHT NINETY THREE AN
URGENT PASSAGE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN.
USE.
THANKS I APPRECIATE IT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
READ WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION.
ALSO HERE FOR A CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AS WELL
AS GUNNERS A CALIFORNIA.
AND I CANNOT RECALL OF MISS
LYNCH'S CLIENTS BUT THERE'S A
BILL GOING ON AND ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY RIGHT NOW SO -
THEY WERE UNABLE TO MAKE IT UP
HERE BUT WERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL -- CALIFORNIA HAS
INCREDIBLY STRICT LAWS IN ORDER
TO PURCHASE A FIREARM CITY
CALIFORNIA.
YOU NED A FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATE YOU NEED TO PASS A
BACKGROUND CHECK YOU NEED TO
FILL OUT ALL THE APPROPRIATE
PAPERWORK.
YOU NEED TO WAIT TEN DAYS ON
JULY FIRST WE'RE GONNA START
HAVING REGISTRATION AND
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON AMMUNITION
AND WILL HAVE TO BE PURCHASED.
IN PERSON FROM A DEALER.
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE LAWS
TO GO WITH THE MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED LAWS A GUN LAWS IN HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ALL THOSE LAWS APPLY.
AT GUN SHOWS JUST BECAUSE A GUN
SHOW IS HAPPENING DOESN'T MEAN
THERE'S A DIFFERENT SET OF
STANDARDS THAT TAKES PLACE
[inaudible]
AND SO.
WE HAVE THIS ATTACK ON THIS THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS WERE WERE
LAW ABIDING GUN OWNERS CAN
GATHER AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO TO SHARE SIMILAR
INTERESTS FOR FOR TRAINING FOR
EDUCATION TO FIND OUT WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE OUT THERE SO
PEOPLE CAN GATHER ON PUBLICLY ON
STATE PROPERTY. TO TO CONDUCT
THIS LAWFUL ACTIVITIES STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT THAT GUNS
PURCHASED FROM GUN SHOWS ARE NOT
ANY MORE LIKELY TO BE USED IN
CRIMES.
AND LET'S RECALL WITH
CALIFORNIA'S TEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD NO ONE IS GOING TO A GUN
SHOW AND PURCHASING A FIREARM
AND LEAVING IT WITH IT THAT DAY
IT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE
[inaudible]
SO.
I THINK THAT THIS THIS MEASURES.
JUST NOT GONNA HAVE A PUBLIC
SAFETY BENEFIT TO GO ALONG WITH
IT.
AND IT'S RIGHT NOW AS YOU HEARD
IT SUBJECT TO PENDING LITIGATION --
IT'S I BELIEVE THERE'S A MAN A
HEARING ON THE MERITS COMING UP
NEXT WEEK I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
LET THIS TO PLAY OUT.
OF BEFORE RUSHING INTO THIS
SIMILAR LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
VETOED SEVERAL TIMES -- AND UP
WITH THAT THAT WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HIDE ANY COMMENTS -- GLORIA I
MEAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE INSPECT
WE ASK THE COMMITTEES HAVE OF IS
THERE -- DID WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION -- ROLL
CALL.
MOTIONS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MORE LOCK
NO MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN SINCE
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF MISSING
MEMBERS -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PERSONS IN THE BILL AND WE
WILL YOU DON'T HAVE A SECOND ONE
SO.
THANK YOU AND HAVE NO OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO WE WILL NOW GO TO
AN ITEM -- TWELVE AB -- THIRTEEN
NINETY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY MAKES A MINOR
EXPANSION TO THE TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOUTH PILOT PROGRAM THAT IS
IN EFFECT.
IN A FEW COUNTIES ALAMEDA BIãU
NAPA NEVADA SANTA CLARA AND
VENTURA AND THEY PROBATION CHIEF
IN SANTA CLARA CAME TO ME AND
WANTED TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM
JUST A LITTLE BIT BY EXTENDING
THE AGE.
FROM TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY FIVE
BASED ON ALL THE BRAIN SCIENCE A
LOT OF THE POLICY THAT'S BEEN
MOVING TO THE LEGISLATURE LATELY.
WE RECOGNIZE THE THAT THAT.
YOUTH OFFENDERS UP TO THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES AS THEY GROW AND AS
THEY MATURE WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE IS THAT WE ALIGN THIS
PROGRAM.
WITH THE AGE WITH THE REST OF
THE POLICIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE TRANSITIONALPROGRAMS
ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY THE
IMPLEMENTATION THE COUNTIES IS
VOLUNTARY BUT THOSE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE USED IT ARE STARTING
TO SHOW SOME REAL BENEFITS.
BY IN.
BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS.
PARTS OF THEIR POPULATION IN
JUVENILE HALLS AND WITHIN THE
PROBATION SYSTEM AND THE ADDRESS
THE ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE
GETTING THEM.
REMEDIATED BACK INTO SOCIETY AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE WITH.
WE CAN HEAR FROM THE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF AT
COULD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA -- PLEASE TO SPONSOR
THIS AND AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LEADERSHIP ON ON
THIS JUST A FEW COMMENTS THIS
REALLY IS -- BASED OFF OF
ADOLESCENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT --
RESEARCH THAT SPEAKS TO AGE
TWENTY FIVE IS BEING THE AGE IN
WHICH THIS POPULATION I THINK
POSES ON FROM A SPECIAL UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THEM FOR AGE APPROPRIATE AN
INTENSIVE SERVICES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AS A FAMILY MEMBER NOTED -- THIS
IS -- VOLUNTARY ON BEHALF OF THE
DEFENDANT THIS IS BUILT UPON A
MODEL IN WHICH ALL OF THE LOCAL
ENTITIES IMPLEMENTING IT ARE IN
AGREEMENT THERE'S A A
COLLABORATIVE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM APPROACH TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT WORKS FOR THAT JURISDICTION --
AND SO WE THINK THAT THERE'S ARE
A GOOD GOOD THING SET IN PLACE I
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE AGAIN
ARE ARE BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE BEST A PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
TO THIS POPULATION.
ARE GOING FORWARD SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY.
GREAT THREE OF OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS THE
NATION VOTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND THE VENTURA COUNTY
BORDERS VISORS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY THANK YOU.
GREAT ANY OTHERS.
HARD TO HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RATING NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONY TO LIKE CLOSE.
ASK YOU HAVE A GREAT WE'VE GOT
ANY COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- WHAT'S THE
ROLE CALL.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
WE'LL KEEP AN EYE CALL SINCE YOU
IS YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE SOME
MISSING MEMBERS THANKS SO MUCH
THE SENATE.
AND WE'LL GO NOW TO ITEM
THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THIS BILL ELIMINATES THE FEE FOR
PETITIONING THE COURT TO SEAL
JUVENILE RECORD.
CURRENT LAW PASSED FOUR YEARS
AGO WAVES THE FEE FOR
INDIVIDUALS UP TO THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
WAIVE THE FEE FOR PERSONS OF ANY
AGE -- THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND WITH ME IS ERIN
RIGHT BURKE WITH [inaudible]
THE ASSOCIATION.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN
RECENT YEARS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS ADDRESSED THE
REGRESSIVE AND RACIALLY
DESPERATE.
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP ON YOUTH AND
FAMILIES IN THE JUVENILE.
JUSTICE SYSTEM BY REDUCING FINES
AND FEES BUT PASSED EGISLATION
THAT MADE THE SEALING OF
JUVENILE RECORDS AUTOMATIC AND
FREE ONLY APPLIED TO CERTAIN
GROUPS.
LEFT OUT WAS A SMALL BOOK
VULNERABLE POPULATION MANY OF
WHOM CANNOT AFFORD A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLAR FILING FEE.
AS A MATTER OF POLICY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZES THE
BENEFIT OF RECORD CEILING IN THE
REHABILITATION OF YOUTH HAS
ALREADY REMOVED MOST OF THE
BARRIERS TO CEILING A JUVENILE
RECORD. FOR THESE REASONS AND
MORE CJ'S PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIRTEEN NINETY FORMER CORPORATE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR IPHONE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICK BROKE
HIM YES THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
ART DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEN.
NINE AM.
WE HAVE A MOTION ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAILY WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING THIS BILL -- IT --
CERTAINLY THE OTHER EFFORTS
WE'VE MADE IN STATUTE -- TO
FACILITATE THE SEALING OF
JUVENILE RECORDS PROBABLY DIDN'T --
ANTICIPATE THAT -- THAT WE
SHOULD REALLY MAKE IT NO MATTER
WHAT AGE YOU ARE SO -- I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL DO.
DID YOU OF GO AHEAD SAID I JUST
TRY TO SAY THAT I APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THE BILL FORWARD -- WE'RE
LOOKING BROADLY AT THE
ELIMINATION OF A NUMBER FEES
ACROSS THE BOARD SO I CERTAINLY
HOPE PROPONENTS WILL LOOK
FAVORABLY ON THOSE EFFORTS AS
WELL.
THANK YOU I'LL BE SUPPORT.
RIGHT WILL DO A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WIENER.
ARE THE BILL WILL STAY ON CALL
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
ALRIGHT SO WE WILL NOW GO TO
ITEM FIFTEEN AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS.
A STRANGE STATUTES -- ALLOW
JUVENILE RECORDS TO BE SEALED
BUT THIS CAN CREATE A CONFLICT
FOR BOTH PROSECUTORS AND DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS.
WITH RESPECT TO OBTAINING
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
DISCHARGE OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATIONS TO PRODUCE DISCOVERY --
THIS BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
WOULD AMEND TO STATUTES THE
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE IN THE
PENAL CODE. TO ALLOW PROSECUTORS
TO SEEK ACCESS TO INSPECTOR USE
SEAL JUVENILE RECORDS.
IN ORDER TO MEET THE STATUTORY
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
DISCLOSE EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE TO
A DEFENDANT [inaudible]
IT WILL.
I THINK YOU CUT DOWN ON SOME
TRIAL DELAYS AND I HAVE SOME
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
MY WIFE TRY TO JUVENILE CASE
LAST YEAR.
IN SALES WAS WAS YOUR RECORD AND
ONE OF THE ACCUSING WITNESSES
HAD SOME.
EVIDENCE POTENTIALLY IN A POLICE
REPORT OF OF DISHONESTY THAT WAS
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE -- BECAUSE
OF THEIR CURRENT.
SORT OF LABYRINTH WAY THIS
STATUTE SET UP.
IT WAS QUITE DIFFICULT TO GET
THOSE RECORDS WE END UP HAVING
TO CONTINUE THE TRIAL.
WITH ULTIMATELY GOT DONE AND
THEY WERE USED IN THE TRIAL BUT
I THINK.
IT'S A GOOD CHANGE IN LAW THAT
WILL HELP PROSECUTORS DISCHARGE
THEIR DUTIES MAKE SURE THEY'RE
NOT.
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
BRADY OBLIGATIONS THAT IT WILL
HELP DEFENSE ATTORNEYS -- OBTAIN
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
OBTAIN OR TO PROPERLY DEFEND
THEIR CLIENTS.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IT
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY UNANIMOUSLY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND TIFFANY MATTHEWS WITH A
CDA IS HERE AS WELL TO PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING FIFTY MATHIS ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
THE SPONSORS OF THE SPELL.
THIS WILL EXPAND THE PROSECUTORS
ABILITY TO ACCESS A SEALED
JUVENILE RECORD FOR THE LIMITED
PURPOSE OF COMPLYING WITH OUR
DISCOVERY OBLIGATION.
THERE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE
PROSECUTOR HAS A WITNESS.
AND WE ARE AWARE THAT THE
WITNESS HAS A JUVENILE RECORD
BUT IT FIELD.
THIS INFORMATION MAY PROVIDE
EXCULPATORY OR FAVORABLE
EVIDENCE FOR THE DEFENDANT AND
THAT'S WHERE ALL THE CATER TO
PROVIDE IT.
AND JUST BECAUSE WE PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT
WILL BE ADMISSIBLE.
THE JUDGE STILL HAS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE PROBATIVE VALUE IS
SUBSTANTIALLY OUTWEIGHED BY THE
DANGERS OF UNDUE PREJUDICE.
THIS BILL BOUNCES THE PROTECTION
OF JUVENILE RECORDS IN THE
PROSECUTOR'S DUTY TO ENSURE THAT
THE DEFENDANT GETS A FAIR TRIAL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE.
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
LA DA HAS REQUESTED THAT I GIVE
ME TWO ON THEIR BEHALF.
OKAY.
RATING KNOWN AS THEIR COMMANDER --
DISCUSSION BY QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
RIGHT TIME.
I HAVE A MOTION AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM DO WANT TO
CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
GREAT.
RIGHT THE MOTION IS -- TO PASS --
DOESN'T GO TO APPROACH -- LINKS
TO A ROLL CALL SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
OR LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL MITCHELL I'M
AROUND.
WIENER.
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN SINCE
AS YOU CAN SEE WE ARE MISSING
MEMBERS BUT THANKS SO MUCH.
AND WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
SIXTEEN AJ ARE FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND WE'RE VERY.
THANKFUL THAT THE FIRE SEEMS TO
BE CONTAINED [inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS LIVE IN OR DO STE AJ
ARE FOR TO URGE CONGRESS TO
SWITCH WITH HOUSE.
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHT THE
BIPARTISAN BACKGROUND CHECKS ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS
LAW HELPS REDUCE THE TRAGEDIES
OF GUN VIOLENCE BY KEEPING
FARMER FIRE ARMS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT
HAVE THEM.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE ALREADY
PASSED LAWS TO REQUIRE UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS WITHOUT ANY
LOOPHOLES.
HOWEVER UNTIL WE BRING THIS
EFFECTIVE FOREIGN POLICY TO THE
WHOLE COUNTRY A DANGEROUS
LOOPHOLE IN FEDERAL GUN LAW WILL
STILL EXEMPTS UNLICENSED SELLERS
FROM HAVING TO PERFORM ANY
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WHAT SO EVER BEFORE SELLING A
FIREARM?
THIS GAP IN FEDERAL LAW LEAVES
PEOPLE EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SUBJECT TO THE DANGERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO CANNOT PASS A
BACKGROUND CHECK.
OBTAINING FIREARMS FROM
UNLICENSED SELLERS OUT OF STATE.
BY PASSING AG ARE FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA LEADERS IN CONGRESS
AND OUR PRESIDENT WILL RECEIVE
THE MESSAGE LOUD AND CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIA FORMALLY AND PUBLICLY
DEMANDS.
THE SPEEDY PASSAGE IN SIGNING OF
HRT.
I ASKED FOR A VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF YOU HAVE
SOME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOU CAN JUST GO UP TO THE
STANDING MICHAELIS REVELING
TESTIMONY GO AHEAD.
REBECCA GONZALEZ VOLUNTEER WITH
BRADY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVIST STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GREAT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD DâN RE
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
ALSO HERE FOR CALIFORNIA RIFLE.
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AS WELL
WERE IN OPPOSITION -- TO AG ARE.
FOR JUST LAST OCTOBER IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION RESEARCH PROGRAM A UC
DAVIS AND THE CENTER FOR POLICY
RESEARCH AT JOHN HOPKINS.
ACTUALLY PUBLISH THEIR FINDING
ON STUDYING CALIFORNIA'S
EXPANDED BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
LOOKING AT OUR ROUGHLY TWENTY
YEAR HISTORY OF EXPANDED
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND THEY FOUND
THAT -- THESE EXPANDED CHECKS AS
WELL AS THE EXTENSION OF CERTAIN
MISDEMEANOR CRIMES HAD NO IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA'S HOMICIDE RATE.
SO WE HAVE A TWENTY YEAR
EXPERIENCE.
THURMOND HERE THAT THAT IT'S
JUST NOT.
PROVIDING WHAT WHAT WAS -- WHAT
WAS INTENDED AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS YOU'RE YOU'RE
TAKING A LAWFUL ACTIVITY IN YOUR
PUTTING A LOT OF RESTRICTIONS ON
VERY COMMON TRANSFERS?
BECAUSE EXPAND BACKGROUND CHECKS
DON'T JUST COVER SALES OF
FIREARMS IT'S ANYTIME YOU'RE
RELINQUISHING POSSESSION.
YOU'RE NEEDING TO GO DOWN TO A
GUN SHOW ARE A GUN STORE IN
PERFORMANCE CHECK PAY A FEE --
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S THAT'S TWO
TRIPS SO IF YOU WANNA LOAN YOUR
FIREARM TO SOMEONE -- FOR
UNSPECIFIED PURPOSE IN
CALIFORNIA THE ONLY THING THAT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY LOAN YOUR
FIREARM FOR IS TO A LICENSE
HUNTER -- YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS PAY A
FEE -- EXCEPT -- UNLESS IT'S IN
YOUR PRESENCE AND WHAT HAPPENS
WITH A LOT OF THESE LAWS WE'VE
SEEN A MOVEMENT -- TO TRY AND
AND CAPTURE THESE UNLICENSED
TRANSFERS -- IS YOU'RE REALLY
NOT CAPTURING CRIMINALS
CRIMINALS ARE NOT GOING THROUGH
THE LAWFUL MEANS AND THERE'S
ALREADY LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT
PROHIBIT.
PRETTY PERSONS FROM FROM
ACQUIRING FIREARMS IT'S A FELONY
AND GENERALLY A AN INFRACTION --
ON THE THE BACKGROUND CHECK IS A
MISDEMEANOR IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT ONE AT THAT TO PROVE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A STATURE
LIMITATIONS IN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO PROVE WHERE THE GUN FROM CAME
FROM.
WHEN IT GOT ACTUALLY TRANSFERRED
IF IT FELL WITHIN THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS AND WE KNOW THAT --
VIOLATIONS BACKGROUND CHECKS
AREN'T AREN'T ALWAYS.
PROSECUTED RIGHT SO WE NEED TO
START ENFORCING EXISTING LAWS ON
THE BOOKS ACTUALLY A PARTIAL
PENALTIES FOR PROHIBITED PERSONS
AND NOT -- TIE UP LAW ABIDING
PEOPLE -- WITH WITH THE
ADDITIONAL RED TAPE WHEN YOU
HAVE SOMEONE WHO MAYBE EVEN HAS
A CCW THAT YOU'RE GONNA LOAN A
GUN.
I'M SO THEY COULD TRY IT OUT OR
MAYBE FOR SELF PROTECTION OR
MAYBE YOU'RE IN A SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE -- CRISIS IN THE
HOME AND YOU NEED TO GET THAT
FARM OUT TO A NEIGHBOR AND YOU
COULD BE RUNNING AFOUL TO
CERTAIN LAW SO.
WITH THAT IN MANY OTHER REASONS
WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR OKAY.
AT THE I AGO EVERYTHING THAT MY
MY MY COLLEAGUES SAID AND
INSTEAD OF GOING INTO A LOT OF
MORE MORE DIALOGUE IS TO THE THE
SPECIFICS OF THE RESOLUTION I I
WOULD LIKE.
TO READ TO YOU WHAT WOULD JESSE
UNRUH SAID ABOUT ABOUT
RESOLUTIONS F IF THAT WOULD BE
OKAY -- AS PART OF MY TESTIMONY --
JESSE UNDER SAYS I CAN TELL YOU
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
RESOLUTIONS WHEN THEY GET TO
WASHINGTON DC THEY COME IN THE
MAIL TO THE CONGRESSMEN OR
SENATORS OFFICE AND THEY GO
STRAIGHT INTO THE ROUND FILE.
THIS THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
POINT IN DOING THEM EXCEPT TO
CAUSE CONTROVERSY IMPROVE
PROVOKED DEBATES ON THE FLOOR
THAT TAKE UP A LOT OF OUR TIME.
THEY ARE USELESS THAT WAS WITH
JESSE UNRUH SAID AND AND THAT
THAT'S KIND OF OUR POSITION ON
ON THE RESOLUTIONS IF WE WANT TO
TALK POLICY LET'S TALK POLICY WE
DO IT ALL THE TIME.
WE WE COME FROM DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES BUT A RESOLUTION IN
THIS CASE IS A IS A IS A LOT OF
A MOTION THAT.
DOES NOTHING AND AND THEN I
DON'T THINK THAT ANY OF US HAVE
THE TIME TO TO SPEND ON ON DOING
THAT SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION AND I QUOTE.
THE ILLUSTRIOUS FORMER SPEAKER
JESSE UNDER.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION IS THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT -- WE'VE
HAD A COUPLE OF DISCUSSIONS ON
ARE GONE BILLS TODAY AND WE FED --
SIMILAR OPPOSITION AND SIMILAR
SUPPORT -- BUT CALIFORNIA DOES
HAVE SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF IN
OVER YEARS WITH DIDN'T ACT MEANT
OF OUR AREA STRONG.
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION LAWS WE
HAVE REDUCED GUN VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA AS COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE NOT ENACTED
SUCH LAWS.
SO.
WITH THAT.
YOU MAY CLOSE -- ELEVEN STATES
ALREADY HAVE A BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND I THINK THAT WITH THE
PASSAGE OF HR EIGHT THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES WILL BE PROTECTED.
BY A UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECK
REQUIREMENT FOR GUN PURCHASES
WHETHER FROM A LICENSE
UNLICENSED DEALER.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
ASKED FOR AYE VOTE.
RIGHT WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
FLOOR CORRECT.
SO IT'S JUST BE ADOPTED OKAY --
I AM THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
IDEN FIFTEEN NON FAMILIAR ONE TO
ME BUT THAT'S OKAY.
ANYWAY WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
SORRY OF RESOLUTION RESIDENTS
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
ALRIGHT WE WILL -- KEEP THE BILL
ON CALL AND THINK SO MUCH.
AND I'M GOING TO RE OPEN THE
ROLE IN A COUPLE OF THINGS WHILE
WE WAIT FOR OUR FINAL -- OKAY
OKAY.
YEAH I THINK HE WAS YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
RIGHT SO -- WE WILL NOW RE OPEN
THE ROLE ON THOSE BILLS THAT ARE
ON CALL SO THAT THE MEMBERS CAN
ADD ON I HAVE.
SIX AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
VERY SIX ZERO WIENER.
WIENER I SEPARATE AB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY COOLEY MOST IS THE PAST
TO DIGEST TO DISH.
ACCOUNT IS FORTY ZERO BRADFORD.
FOR AYE WIENER WIENER I READ
THAT BILL KNOWS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM EIGHT AB EIGHT
NINE THREE GLORIA MOTION IS TO
PASS THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TO ONE
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE AMARO.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
DO WE WANT TO CALL THE ROLL OF
THUNDER MOREAU [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH.
WE WE WILL NOT CLOSE THE ROLE
JUST IN CASE SENATOR ROBB STRAPS
YOU CAN CHECK AND SEE IF HE'S
GOING TO RETURN OKAY GREAT SO WE
WON'T THEN ON THE OTHER BILLS HE
WASN'T ABLE.
TO A WIN ON YET WE WILL EARN --
DON'T WE START WITH -- OUR LAST
PRESENTER CAN WILL RE OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
OKAY. SEVEN AFTER RECENT MY
THING OF THAT THEY'RE OUT RATE
[inaudible]
BANKING.
MISTER CHAIR.
MADAM A SEED WITH YOUR ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN HA ARE.
FIVE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS AG ARE FIVE URGES TO
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO USE
CALIFORNIA AS A MODEL FOR
REASONABLE FIREARM SAFETY AS WE
WORK TO PASS NATIONAL FIREARMS
SAFETY REGULATION.
IN COMPARISON THE REST OF THE
NATION CALIFORNIA RANKED THIRD
IN GUN HOMICIDES AND SIXTEEN AND
GUN DEATHS AND THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES BUT BY TWENTY
SIXTEEN IMPROVED TO TWENTY FIFTH
IN GUN HOMICIDES PER CAPITA.
WITH THE EIGHTH LOWEST RATE OF
GUN RELATED DEATHS NATIONWIDE.
THIS IMPROVEMENT WAS ONLY
POSSIBLE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
PASSED LEGISLATION AIMED AT
CLOSING ANY LOOPHOLES OR
CONFUSION ON FIREARM SAFETY AND
OWNERSHIP WITHIN THIS STATE.
AS MENTIONED IN AGE ARE IF
SOMEONE IS CONVICTED OF A HATE
CRIME IN CALIFORNIA THAT PERSON
IS PROHIBITED FROM PURCHASING
AND POSSESSING FIREARMS.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIRST STATE TO
ENACT A GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER KNOWN AS AN EXTREME RISK
PROTECTION ORDER IN MOST STATES.
IN CALIFORNIA PERSONS PROHIBITED
FROM PURCHASING MULTIPLE GO HAND
GUNS IN A SINGLE SALE.
CALIFORNIA JURORS FIREARM USERS
ARE PROTECTED FROM SPEND SAY
FIREARMS BY PER PER PROHIBITING
THE MANUFACTURING IMPORTATION
I'M SAFE GUNS INTO THE STATE.
IS IMPORTANT NOTE THAT NOT ONLY
ARE WE WORKING TOWARDS ENDING
GUN VIOLENCE IN THE STATE WE
HAVE MADE A PRIORITY TO
UNDERSTAND THE ROOT.
CAUSE BY CREATING A FIRE ARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER AT UC
DAVIS CALIFORNIA'S PROVEN.
STRONGER FIREARM SAFETY LAWS CAN
LEAD TO REDUCE RATES OF GUN
VIOLENCE WHICH INSURES PUBLIC
SAFETY.
WHILE SOME MIGHT ARGUE THIS
RESOLUTION IS NOT NEEDED LET ME
POINT THEM TO AN FBI STATED IT
FOUND 75% OF FIREARMS USED IN A
MASS SHOOTING WERE PURCHASED
LEGALLY.
AJ ARE FIVE IS NEEDED TO LET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT KNOW THAT IS
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PUBLC THAT THIS NATION ADDRESS
GUN VIOLENCE BY CREATING
UNIVERSAL FIREARM STANDARD
SAFETY STANDARDS THAT ARE STRONG
AND SENSIBLE.
CONTINUE TO SUBJECT OUR
COMMUNITY TO THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING CAUSED BY GUN VIOLENCE
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE WHEN WE HAVE
A PROBLEM WE HAVE A WHEN WE HAVE
A PROVEN WAY.
OF REDUCING GUN VIOLENCE GUN
VIOLENCE IS A DISEASE THAT IS
DESTROYING LIFE IN THIS TIME WE
GET SERIOUS ABOUT ADDRESSING
THIS DISEASE HERE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AS AMANDA
WILCOX FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS OF BRADY UNITED AGAINST
GUN VIOLENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GEICO.
HI YOU KNOW OUR NEW NAME BETTER
THAN ME.
DOESN'T ROLL OFF MY TONGUE AT
YES AMANDA WILCOX WITH OPERATING
CALIFORNIA HAS THAT.
SOMEWHERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION OBVIOUSLY.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THE
STOCKTON SCHOOLYARD SHOOTING
HAPPENED A CLEVELAND ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL A NUMBER OF I THINK THEY
WERE SECOND GRADERS MAINLY WERE
KILLED.
A TEACHER WAS INJURED AND IT
SHOOK THAT COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
OUR STATE.
AND ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS AFTER
THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S STARTED TO ENACT
SOME OF THE STRONGEST GUN LAWS
INCLUDING UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECK.
THAN TEN DAY WAITING PERIOD THE
FIRST AND I IN OUR NATION'S
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN.
AND MANY OTHERS OF WE'VE
CONTINUED TO ENACT LAWS I
STARTED WORKING AS AN ADVOCATE
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO MANY LAWS HAVE
BEEN.
PASSED UNDER MY WATCH -- IN
DURING THAT TIME SINCE THE HIGH
NINETEEN NINETY THREE AS YOU'VE
HEARD OUR GUN DEATH RATE DROPPED
DRAMATICALLY -- ALMOST FOUR
TIMES THE DROP IN THE REST OF
THE NATION AND I'D LIKE TO ADD
BECAUSE I KNOW THE OPPOSITION
WILL SAY IT'S ABOUT BEING TOUGH
ON CRIME AND THREE STRIKES.
THAT OVER HALF OUR GUN DEATHS
ARE BY SUICIDE.
AND TO REDUCE FARM VIOLENCE ONE
NEEDS TO REDUCE.
SUICIDE BY FIREARM AND WE HAVE
SEEN A SIGNIFICANT DROP THERE AS
WELL AND THAT'S NOT A CRIMINAL
ISSUE -- IT IS VERY FRUSTRATING
THAT WE SEE THESE THAT ARE LOST
HIM THAT KIND OF AFFECTING
CALIFORNIA AND WE SEE NOTHING
HAPPENING NATIONALLY -- LAWS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY -- BILLS HAVE
BEEN INTRODUCED IN -- WASHINGTON
ARE ALL LWS THAT ARE ALREADY ON
THE BOOKS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS -- EXTREMIST ORDERS IS
CALLED NATIONALLY OR DVR -- LAWS
PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO THE STATE
THERE'S A BILL -- TO FONG G
MBINES PREVENTION RESEARCH ALL
THINGS THAT WE DO IN CALIFORNIA
IT IS SO FRUSTRATING THAT THESE
LAWS DO NOT MOVE EVEN THOUGH
PUBLIC OPINION SHOWS VERY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THESE MEASURES --
BUT CALIFORNIA IS TAKING THE
LEAD ON MANY ISSUES THE ACTUALLY
THE NATION HAS OFTEN FOLLOWED.
AND I HOPE THEY WILL ON THIS AND
I APPLAUD CALIFORNIA THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MAKING A
STATEMENT THAT -- THE REST OF
THE NATION TO FOLLOW OUR LEAD
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE CHAIRS --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
I'VE WORKED WITH BOTH OF YOU FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS -- BY PEERS
AND OTHER STATES ARE VERY
ENVIOUS OF WHAT WE CAN DO IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE LEGISLATORS
THAT I GET TO WORK WITH.
THANK YOU ALL.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DANIELLE CANDOR
BECAUSE OUR BEHALF OF THE
GIFFORDS LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FOR THE RECORD AND RE
WITH NATIONAL RIGHT TO
ASSOCIATION ALSO YOUR FIRST YEAR
I BROUGHT A VISUAL AIDTHIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA GUN LAWS BOOK
IT'S PUT TOGETHER BY -- OUR
ATTORNEYS AND IT'S MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED PAGES -- IT COVERS.
MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED STATE
LAWS STATE TRANSCEND ALL VARIOUS
CODE SECTIONS BEING A GUN OWNER
CALIFORNIA'S VERY DIFFICULT
THERE'S A LOT TO KNOW.
THE LAWS ARE VERY CONFUSING AND
THEIR EVER CHANGING EACH YEAR WE
DEAL WITH DOZENS UPON DOZENS OF
PROPOSALS -- SOME IN ACTED
SUMMER NOT -- AND THIS BOOK IS
HAS BEEN UPDATED ANNUALLY FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND WE HAVE [inaudible]
JUST.
THERE'S JUST A LOT TO REMEMBER
AS A GUN OWNER AND YOU COULD.
CONSTANTLY AT RISK OF OF OF
LOSING YOUR RIGHTS BECAUSE OF AN
INFRACTION TO ONE OF THESE LAWS --
WE'VE HEARD SEVERAL BILLS
INCLUDING A TRANSPORTATION BILL
IN THIS COMMITTEE EARLIER THIS
YEAR THAT COULD RESULT IN A FIVE
YEAR PROBATION -- WITH WITH SOME
OF THE LAWS I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE INTENTION BEHIND AMMAR THEIR
THEIR WELL INTENDED AND THEY'VE --
FOCUS MORE ON THE INSTRUMENT
RATHER THAN THE BAD ACTORS AND
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S
MISGUIDED WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
THOSE WHO ARE ABUSING OUR LAWS --
WE HAVE A HUGE BACKLOG ON THE
APP SYSTEM WE'VE THROWN MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY FOCUS ON THOSE WHO ARE
PROHIBITED.
THOSE WHO ARE OUT THERE MISS
USING FIREARMS -- ONE THING I
WANTED TO TOUCH ON LAST WEEK
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION THIS
COMMITTEE -- ON ACTUALLY -- A
BILL -- ON DAY SEEKING AND
ROSTER AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THERE'S SEVERAL TIMES WE SEEN
EXEMPTIONS THEY'RE TRYING TO
EXEMPTS CERTAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FROM HAVING TO USE
ROSTERED AND GUNS AND I THINK
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION ON ON
THAT BILL -- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
NOT HAD A NEW MODEL
SEMIAUTOMATIC FIREARM ADDEDTO
THE THE SAFE HANDGUN ROSTER
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE BECAUSE THE
STANDARDS ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET.
AND AND THAT JUST GOES ALONG
WITH THE LAWSUIT SO GUN OWNERS
ARE ARE NOT.
OF A THIRD THERE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT ARE JUST BEING BANNED
BECAUSE OF OUR LAWS THAT ARE
WELL MADE WHILE THE UNDERLYING
LONG MAY BE WELL INTENTIONED --
TO TO GO AFTER CERTAIN GUNS WERE
WERE NOT ABLE TO PURCHASE THE
LATEST AND MOST RELIABLE AND
SAFEMODELS.
AND AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE'S A PUBLIC SAFETY BENEFIT
TO THAT WHEN WERE EXEMPTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GET THOSE MODELS AS WELL
AND SO -- I'M HAPPY TO TO
DISCUSS THAT BILL AT ANOTHER
TIME I KNOW THAT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR NOW -- BUT BUT
THE LAWS ARE ARDUOUS ON ONE LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THE CRIMINAL MISUSE.
I MEAN THERE'S PLENTY LAWS ON
THE BOOKS TO DO THAT THANK YOU.
BEFORE NEXT WITNESS JUST AS A
POINT OF CORRECTION THE APPS
BACKLOG IS GREATLY REDUCED
[inaudible]
ON PLEASE PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF SAMPER'S
REPRESENTING -- GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA AND AND WITH A GREAT
RESPECT WITH TO THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SOME.
VERY VERY GOOD CONVERSATIONS
OFTEN -- TO DISCUSS THE THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF OF GUN VIOLENCE
AND GUN POLICY -- WE'D WE
DISAGREE ON A LOT OF THE
APPROACHES -- IN AND AT LEAST WE
DISAGREE HERE THAT THAT THE THE
A TRYING TO MAKE -- THE
CALIFORNIA THE STANDARD FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY -- HIS
SEASON IS NOT A REAL GOOD IDEAS
MATTER FACT THIS MORNING AT FIVE
THIRTY IN THE MORNING I WAS
CALLED BY RADIO STATION.
IN SAINT LOUIS THAT WAS ASKING
US TO PLEASE.
IMPLORING US TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T IN FACT THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY WITH THEIR
SECOND AMENDMENT POLICIES WHICH
IS THEIR TERM NOT MINE.
ANNA AND I JUST FINISHED MY
COMMENTS WITH THE A DOODLE ON ON
SPEAKER ON WAS COMMENTS ON
RESOLUTION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUES.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
RESPECTFULLYASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- ROLL CALL.
AND THIS IS BE ADOPTED.
SKINNER KNEW -- HI SKINNER AYE
AND MORE LACKEY.
WELL LOOK NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON AYE JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU.
RONA WIENER WIENER AYE.
ALL RIGHT THAT TIME AJ OURS OUT
IT IS.
FIVE TWO THANKS SO MUCH VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
ON THOSE ITEMS WHERE MEMBERS CAN
OUT ON SO.
WE CAN JUST.
AB EIGHT NINE THREE GLORIA MUCH
DOES DO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT FOCUS.
FIVE TO ONE YEAH FIVE TO ONE
MORALE.
WHICH BILL AB EIGHT NINE THREE
GLORIA.
NUMBER EIGHT I TO ME.
NOW MY ROUND OUT.
ALL RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE TWO AB THIRTEEN NINETY MARK
STONE MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
FLOOR CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO
ZERO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
THIS IS.
A NINETY NUMBER.
TWELVE HI.
JACKSON AYE MORALE.
MORALE NO WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
ALL RIGHT AB THIRTEEN NINETY IS
OUT.
SIX ONE AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR
DAILY MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ZERO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE MORALE.
AROUND NOW WINNER WIENER AYE.
ALL RIGHT AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FOUR IS OUT.
SIX TWO ONE AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN CUNNINGHAM MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FLOOR CURRENT VOTE
THREE TO ZERO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON
HIGH MORALE.
HI WIENER WIENER HI.
HARD AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS
OUT.
SEVEN ZERO LAST ONE AJ ARE FOR
AGUIAR-CURRY MOST THIS BE
ADOPTED TO THE FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HIGH MORALE AROUND NOW.
AJ ARE FOR IS OUT FIVE TWO I
THINK THERE WAS ONE THAT SENATOR
MORALES.
YOU GOT THAT ALREADY OKAY.
WE OTHERWISE [inaudible]
YEAH. ONE OF THE THAT WAS.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ALRIGHT LET'S
JUST MAKE SURE WE GOT EVERYBODY
AND ALL BILLS.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT -- PART PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WILL CONCLUDE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU